uh good evening ladies and gentlemen
members and officers welcome to this
planning committee of the 19th of April
before I go into our main agenda
um I would just like to for members and
officers that are aware
we were notified last week that one of
our colleagues who worked for this
Authority
um planning manager Doug Brown sadly
passed away after a very short illness
he left the authority in 2011
he was well thought off here at the time
became friends with many people
including myself
what I would like to do is just if we
could stand I know not many members here
would know of him or members of the
public but I think it's our duty to pay
respects to a colleague who's no longer
with us so if you wouldn't mind standing
just for a moment
foreign
officers
and messages have been sent to Sue and
his family with our thoughts and
condolences so I'm sure you those again
who would know him I'm not asking
anybody to speak if you don't mind that
so we will carry on excuse the voice
we are being live streamed so uh that's
on the council was YouTube channel and
it is recorded as well and can be seen
after tonight's meeting
the housekeeping once again is if the
fire alarm is activated please vacate
the offices via the stairs either
through the security door on I say the
right left I've said that all the time
I've been up here that it's there but
the stairs opposite the lifts please do
not leave use the lifts assemble on holy
square and when it is deemed safe to
come back in the officers will tell you
and
touchwood it's never happened so and I
hope it doesn't happen on my last one
does anybody intend filming this meeting
tonight
nope
thank you I can hear somebody's
background
walking up there on something
uh pleased with mobile phones can you
turn them to silent
and they are not used to make or receive
phone calls in the chamber whilst this
meeting is in progress
members are requesting to speak under
procedure 20.1
I have counselor Kerry Boyd on item
number four
public speaking the following
applications have been reserved
for public speaking the members please
make a note that agenda item 6A land at
newhane Road Ramsgate
item 6B 54 Stone Road broadstairs
item 6D pair head shelter in broadstairs
and item 6G little Upton valve Road
broadstairs I will come back quickly on
the previous parties there any other
counselor we should speak on 20.1
I didn't think there was so thank you
members
agenda item one apologies for absence I
have apologies for instance from
councilor Auburn also the vice chair
her counselor Coleman cook
I don't know whether there's a
substitute for cancer comical
nope
sorry
I wasn't going to offer you a subject
I was gonna offer you apologies from
councilor Pat Moore
thank you
counselor
I didn't think you would do that thank
you
agenda item two are there any
Declarations of Interest
count it I I apologies for Michael
apologies for Mark rattigan as well
thank you
agenda item three minutes of the
planning meeting held on the 15th of
March the members agree that the updated
minutes which you should received of
that planning committee meeting on the
15th of March be approved as a correct
record could I have a proposer please
councilor Beaufort a second to please
Council roseski thank you very much
moving on to agenda item four speaking
under Council procedure rule 20.1 is
counselor Boyd this is for the Old Forge
High Street Garland Margate
Council avoid thank you chair
um good evening everybody
um firstly thank you for going on a site
visit I hope you enjoyed the not so
Sunny garland that day which was a bit
wet and windy and you are always welcome
in the village so please do come back
um I've got a um a list of points raised
from the residents from that visits and
that I will read out as quickly as I
possibly can because I know you've got a
long time a long agenda this evening but
one thing I do want to reference is
there was something wrong with the
portal and the residents over the past
week or so weren't able to add their
comments on the um planning portal
itself I don't know what's gone wrong
there but just be mindful that there
might actually be comments that haven't
been registered
um so I'll start one the developers
should either wait until the proposed
loud scale development takes place in
the fields behind this property in order
to create appropriate access
alternatively they should consider
knocking the entire existing property
down and building satisfactory and safe
access to and from this new site it
should not be accessible to requests to
claim a section of the public bride away
access simply to squeeze this and plenty
properties onto a private building plot
more cheaply are these four new
properties really bringing such benefit
as to consider sacrificing these
historic Route our predecessors have
fought to protect our Broadways are
precious and serve the public therefore
we should seek to protect every inch we
also feel that permitting this
unnecessary change of use would set a
precedence for bridal waves versus
building sites across the fields of
thanet
the plot of land opposite the existing
property should predominantly be given
to over to our safe passing and towing
of vehicles and Roads users for example
pedestrian sources cyclists at the new
Junction just as there has been an area
allocated for within the main build plot
the existing neighborhood residents
deserve the same protection and
treatment as the new ones will
point three there was a bridal ways
offices report submitted at the end of
March they would like the committee to
give serious attention to it arrived
after the first committee meeting
0.4 is there not a planning rule
regarding Public Access routes that is
there for just that that is if they
serve the front is of more than a
certain number of properties they need
separate paths for pedestrians I.E the
section from the main High Street to the
proposed plot will serve six High Street
plus three in Birds Avenue franchises in
future waste collection whilst neighbors
were pleased the bin presentation area
had been moved to within the main build
site as it should be they had many
concerns about the use of a private
collection contract what happens if or
when the contract fails it can't last
forever who will be responsible in
future who wants to pay maintenance fees
on top of a house price are these buyers
really out there these private waste
Vehicles will need to pass and turn on
the plot opposite of the existing
building the land opposite is still
required to be kept well clear to enable
TDC to continue waste collection for all
existing residents videos of the current
large waste Vehicles servicing this
route have been shared everything points
towards waiting for rear or better and
safer access to his plot than is
proposed in this plan point six during
the build there will be a major major
daily disruption for 40 plus neighbors
of High Street and birds Avenue who use
the High Street entrance many times back
and forth throughout the day the access
route which is proposed for the building
vehicles and deliveries as reported by
all this access Route traffic is
particularly challenging already
maintenance of the road during and most
importantly after these eight 18 ton
hevs ineviting makes the already unfit
for pedestrians horse and vehicles
pothole ridden Access Road even worse we
already damage our vehicles and ankles
regularly will KCC adopt this newly
formed Access Road along with the new
cul-de-sac at the end of the build
can you get a mortgage for a house which
has a door directly onto a road the
future plan for the remaining section of
this existing house again is this type
of property needed desirable achievable
for the local market and finally the
residents of 158 next door have specific
concerns about the breaking of a
planning restriction regarding Windows
along their adjoining boundary facing
land along with blocking of light and
major overshedding of their entire
entire plot which the buildings proposed
for the entire length of their South
phase and boardable course they will
hugely block light and sun to the entire
158 plot for the whole day year round
and that was it
thanks Council Boyd and I think you know
I've been very generous with you they're
going right over time thank you I'm
going to hand over to uh in Mr now
planning applications manager to update
and give you his report
thank you chair
um so the application site is outlined
in Red so the applications for the
direction of four dwellings with
demolition of part of the existing Old
Forge building to facilitate the
vehicular access into the development so
um just a brief reminder
um the main issues for the application
are the consideration of character
appearance of the area living conditions
of Residential Properties adjacent and
surrounding the the site impact on
highways production of safety and
obviously some of the issues that have
been raised in by councilor Boyd's
speech as well another reminder this
site is in the urban confines with the
Strategic allocation to the South which
covers the um the west gate and and
Garland sites
um the era there was also previous
outline permission from 2016 which
approved the the app an application for
four dwellings on the site but for
outline and without the reserve matters
submission coming in so that has
subsequently expired
so very briefly just to show you this is
a 3D from from Google just to show the
site itself so members will recall from
those that visited the site that we were
able to to look at the access road that
serves the dwellings at the moment and
also were able to go onto the site so as
you look at this property which is the
Old Forge the element to the side there
which is two-story with the with the
Gable window sorry the door window and
the roof is to be demolished with a
vehicular access going through
and this is the bridal way that
currently runs down the side of the site
so the site area is effectively on that
diagonal line backwards so the by the
way itself no none of the bridal way is
being lost as part of the development
it's not getting smaller but the actual
the green area that you can see next to
the signpost is to be resurfaced
this is the area opposite
which originally was proposed for a bin
collection point and also some parking
for the old Ford which obviously you can
see it's it's in useful in the photo
so this is the uh on the site at the
moment so the existing layout plan
uh and then this was The Proposal that
was put before members previously so
since the site visit we have received um
a couple of amended details so this
proposal now shows a removal of the
waste collection area in the um
I'm going to call it trapezium to the
left hand side and also changes the
surfacing materials adjacent to the
bridal way so looking at a zoomed in
image so this is that trapezium land so
you can see that there's proposal for
parking for the
um for the Old Forge and then the rest
of it the area is to be tarmac so
previously there was the the bin storage
area
um that goes hand in hand with
um the applicant's intention to provide
private waste collection for the four
properties themselves accessing the site
then
you have the change in detail of
material
delineating the existing sort of tarmac
access which would then run down towards
the public sorry the Bridle way here
with effectively the the site delineated
by some brick sets
um next to the area where which is
currently to be demolished in the Old
Forge with then the vehicular access
coming in to serve the the four
properties we have also had
a an updated construction Environmental
Management plan which states that
following the completion of the
construction works the birds Avenue will
be resurfaced between the High Street
Garland entrance and the site access
which was something that was mentioned
on the site visit as well
so
as mentioned
there has been consultation on the plan
that's come in and I mentioned this on
the site visit that we were going to
update with regards to the comments that
we'd received so we received a comment
from KCC public rights of way following
the planning committee and then
subsequently following this plan being
submitted to the council and so they
have have raised the fact that they
they wouldn't normally agree to tarmac
for part of a bridal way and as I
mentioned for those on the site visit if
I go back to this image it's not
actually definitively clear on the KCC
Maps where the Broadway starts whether
or not it's where the the SP is on this
plan here or whether or not it's
actually a bit further back where the
signpost is however
um it's mentioned by KCC that they would
accept tarmac in this instance just due
to the due to the use of of the the the
you know the access into the site they
have raised a point that they would
query the movement of the existing
signage so you can see it's currently
sort of SP at the the top of the sign if
I go back to the images you'll be able
to see this
that that sign there
so the applicant has shown this move to
the other side of the access
and the cases they have raised the point
that they would want to be consulted on
both any movement of the sign but also
the need for the sign to include more
information about it including the the
point about pedestrians being
prioritized and raising sort of a I
suppose a point so that people are aware
anyone using vehicles that it is a it is
a bridal way and there will be people
using it in addition they have raised a
query about whether or not it would be
possible to have a some form of speed
restriction or on-site
raise platform for vehicles entering the
site as well we've also received
comments from residents we received four
comments um from residents all of which
are are online and they're we're in the
members box as well before the meeting
um I think councilor boy has summarized
them very well in terms of those
concerns that were raised
um we have also received a comment from
the British horse society which raised
concerns about the impact of
construction on the use of the bridal
way as well as vehicular movements when
constructed and they proposed the need
for
updated or better signage potential
speed restrictions and potentially
um that any alterations to the surface
or alignment of the bridal way needs to
be agreed by KCC with the bridal way not
being diminished inside in any way as
well
um so
we've received those those comments
um it's proposed by officers that the
Amendments that have been submitted are
put forward to members as part of our
recommendation to approve and so the
proposal uh has originally submitted in
our view wouldn't have affected the use
of the bridal way because it's not
actually reducing the size of it and
this would keep the access to the bridal
eye open
um obviously originally we were
considering the bin storage area where
it was that has now been removed and
therefore the proposal for a separate
arrangement for waste collection
um in this specific instance would be
considered acceptable but would need to
be conditioned quite clearly to include
details of the collection which would
include matters such as the vehicles to
be used because obviously that width is
is 3.2 meters wide and obviously the
whole problem at the moment is the the
size of the vehicles using that access
point at the moment
so the amended recommendation from
officers so the recommendation is to
approve but that is subject to updating
all of the conditions in the Agenda
Report which you've got which refer to
the old site layout plan with this site
layout plan that you can see on the
screen in front of you to amend
condition three which would therefore
update the construction management plan
as received on the 24th of March which
includes the resurfacing of the the
access road from High Street Garland to
the access to the site
it would change condition 10 so
condition 10 was the condition which
talked about the waste collection area
that would now change to the following
condition which would state that Pride's
the first occupation of the development
here by permitted these was the
arrangements for Waste and Recycling
storage and collections should be
submitted to an approved in writing by
the local planning Authority these
details shall include arrangements for
Waste and Recycling to be stored and
collected from within the new
development the arrangements and
measures should there shall be provided
in accordance with approved details and
thereafter maintained
um The Proposal would the pros
recommendation would also amend
condition 15 so condition 15 is the
Landscaping condition which would
include details of the species of the
trees that they're proposing in the site
and details of the heart and soft sort
of material sort of the hard landscaping
materials that condition is proposed to
be updated
and the particular elements be updated
there are that the materials proposed
for all hard surfaced areas beyond the
limits of the highway including the type
and color and including the area of
parking to the Old Forge should be
submitted as well as that the precise
location and design of any replacement
or retained signage for the public
Bridal way and for all of the
Landscaping that that would be subject
to being submitted to the local planning
Authority and we could only approve that
in consultation following consultation
with kcc's public rights of way team so
with those amendments to those
conditions the officer recommendation is
to approve the development thank you
uh thank you Ian I moved the office
recommendation is to approve a good
counselor shop please second second
match
thank you members
over to you
any comments
a few hands going up accounts forever
I think um this was a an example of a
very useful site visit actually because
um I don't think it was easy to
understand
the proximity of the various
areas and the the actual sort of the
geometry of it and the space of it from
um the plants as presented I think it
was something that we did need to see
um it's clearly
not not an ideal arrangement
um
but I'm struggling to see as I quite
often do how we would defend an appeal
if we reject it so I shall listen to
what members have got to say very
carefully thank you thank you Council
Keane thank you just a point of
clarification for me really the private
waste collection
um what what does happen if that
Arrangement falls through at any time
thank you
um so the condition itself um that I
read out um if effectively that wasn't
being adhered to so they've obviously
got to submit the details before they
can occupy any of the dwellings uh the
condition requires that that those
details are to be adhered to ongoing if
for example that wasn't the case then
obviously we would investigate it as a
breach of condition
um obviously the most obvious way that
that would cause a problem is that
effectively there would be an immunity
issue by virtue of bins effectively
waste being potentially put out on the
highway or indeed in this site or indeed
the site
um sort of where the the other bit of
land is which obviously we've removed
the bin storage from so by the condition
we can enforce to ensure that the
arrangements that we agree are adhered
to but then also there will be set there
will be separate
um things that could be dealt with about
effectively fly tipping of waste on on
an area of land so whilst the council
wouldn't necessarily be able to do
anything on land that's not ours there
are streets reinforcement hours of that
but the planning condition is the
primary method that we would be making
sure that is that is enforced it is it's
accepted that because of
I think it is very rare that we've got a
situation like this where the existing
access has dwelling served off here but
it then this comes off that uh and that
then causes the problem with terms of
vehicles and collection points so we we
would not anticipate this this in our
view definitely doesn't set a Preston
because it is incredibly unique we don't
have this sort of thing come up very
often
um but as well as that it's just to
ensure that that that private waste
collection is going to need to have
smaller Vehicles anyway
um to get you know get in and that's one
of the things that obviously we will be
getting details off
thank you councilor bayford
thank you chair unfortunately I was
unable to get to the site visit but when
when this came to us first it seemed
totally unacceptable but I I think the
Great Lengths have been gone to to meet
the concerns of residents
and I share counselor Everett's um
thoughts that we wouldn't really have
reasonable planning reasons to refuse
this now so I I think now I'm happy to
go along with it whereas I certainly
wasn't before thank you thank you
Council Moore yes thank you chair
um just to clarify again about the
private collection that'll be a
condition that that will be ongoing
um and obviously the if it's a private
firm those houses will be paying for
that I presume in some kind of annual
fee
um obviously if they didn't pay that and
that fell through does that condition
force the issue that it must continue
um because that's a private road
unadopted road and I know that the waste
Vehicles will not go down those roads so
they would be back to willing their bins
right to the main roads again so it's
just really whether that condition
enforces that permanently
so the the condition I suppose is only
good as good as the details we get in
um and obviously we the way that the
condition has been worded is to set the
parameters to ensure that actually it
requires collections on on the side to
your point about
um a sort of Maintenance uh or sort of a
fee to a management company to include
the waste collection
um obviously with sites such as this it
is expected that there would be some
sort of Management Company Incorporated
anyway because obviously they the
individual owners are unlike to own that
driveway access in and obviously that
will need to be maintained and there
will likely be a fee from the person the
people so buying those properties so the
condition uh has got to set the
parameters to ensure that there is a
realistic continual waste collection
going on it is obviously it would be an
individual property occupiers decision
to buy a property that has that sort of
clause in the contract for it but
obviously that's the bit about the
awareness of the fact that
um you know the the waste collection for
thalassery Council won't won't cover
these properties and that's something
that will almost you know certainly need
to be communicated we are intending I
haven't outlined it but intended to put
an informative on on that basis to say
that you know you've got an people could
be notified that this is this is the
case but obviously the condition is only
as good as the information we get in
which is why obviously the applicant is
very well aware they need to provide
adequate information
okay thank you Ian can't swing
unfortunately I wasn't able to get to
the site visit either but I just wanted
some clarification on the bridal road so
in the plans it actually looks if
there's a a wall that divides the bridal
way from the present boundary of that
property uh does that wall go and I'm
assuming that that part of the Bride
away that becomes access
for vehicles
so what what's what's going to occur is
from from this image um if you the
return brick wall that you can see there
is effectively removed with that forming
almost the access into that extension on
the side of the property of the Old
Forge goes the the fence that's the
ready Brown fence that runs down the
side of this side so that that is
effectively the boundary of the site
which would be replaced by potentially a
new boundary treatment which is part of
a condition again to get details of that
treatment
um so that is the extent of the site and
will not go into the bridal ways the
Broadway width which is got to be
maintained I think it's 1.2 meters
um it is not changing as part of this
proposal the issue with the by the way
which is certainly understood is is the
fact that you will have vehicles going
over effectively the track bits that you
can see on this on this image and so it
is important that the the changes have
been made to to delineate the start of
the site as opposed to the the start of
the the bridal way
um we feel is appropriate
um with the original outline that was
approved in 2016 it was specifically
considered then as well about is there
an issue with pedestrian safety by
virtue of having vehicles going over
that
um because of the tightness around there
the low speeds of vehicles at that point
and also the number of vehicles even
with four dwellings all those dwellings
aren't going to leave at the same time
that's going to be spread out throughout
the you know the day it's it's it
wouldn't result in a a tangible harm to
pedestrian safety but that is partially
dependent on things like the signage
that we get in uh that you know that
will show that so could I just confirm
that the crossing point for vehicles
would probably just be that brick wall
bit and that you wouldn't have vehicles
going further down the path yeah no
that's that it's just it's just that
it's literally the it's it's 3.2 meters
wide that's it
thank you
um
yeah I mean I I share the concerns that
I had earlier
um from residence both from councilor
Boyd and when we went when I did go on a
site visit and when they were voiced
there about the bridal way
I mean I think it it is
there is no need for the bridal way to
be hindered I don't believe in any way
and brighter ways are important they
should be kept
um access should be kept safe for all
pedestrians and and horse riders as well
there could have been an alternative
here there could have been the accident
you know that there could have been
access through where the house is at the
moment so that came to build three or
four houses at the back to
um
on on their the back Garden they could
have removed the house and done this in
a safe way for pedestrians
horse riders and residents of the new
dwellings it sort of feels to me like
we're the ones who are bending over
backwards to enable the developer to get
everything and more that they want on
this site now all I'm saying on I'm not
sure anything I've said would be a valid
planning reason to object to or to
refuse permission
um people wise have been planning law
than me would be able to to come up with
that but I it it fills me with concern
and I'm I really do not like
this planning application thank you
thank you and yeah I think
I I understand the sentiment in terms of
the the fact that obviously an
alternative proposal could improve above
what they've proposed
um but it is it's it's the obviously the
merits of the case that have come
forward obviously we have got the
um the material planning consideration
that whilst it's not no longer extent
that permission has been granted with
this access point previously in 2016 for
four dwellings on the site so the
principle of that that and an access at
this point has been agreed and that was
agreed by the planning committee at the
time so it it does create a situation
that the the principle of an access here
um nothing has changed in either
legislation significantly enough to
we're on a different decision on that
point but it is accepted and hence the
amendments are necessary to ensure that
we're minimizing any impact as much as
possible
thank you councilor Tony
thank you
um obviously the waste collection seems
to be and has been right from the start
of this particular application uh a
problem
um you're asking this committee to
approve a planning application on the
basis that we have no concrete
information relating to the the
fundamental management of removal of
that waste it falls upon the people who
buy the the properties who eventually
will have to pay for some sort of
agreement
we don't know if this could be a
management company set up or whether
it'll be the freeholders the more with
the Freeholder sells all those
properties or the developer he walks he
has no further responsibility or
involvement
so if that fails
because someone objects to pay or
whatever how do you manage to enforce
the planning that we are going to you're
asking us to approve today for that
waste collection how do we actually get
that working
thank you again
well so first of all I've said as I
mentioned it's about getting the
information before any dwelling can be
occupied so for dwellings occupied
without the arrangement of what they're
proposing to do then obviously that is a
trigger point for a potential breach
condition in terms of the concerns about
enforcing it in obviously after the
after the fact of when it's actually
created obviously the council would have
to look at what the harm is created for
them not adhering with the condition and
obviously in this instance as I've
mentioned fundamentally that may be an
immunity issue if waste isn't being
stored or collected from wherever we
have agreed on site the issue with the
previous proposal for bin collection was
obviously one that's been raised by
residents which is why the applicant has
changed what they're proposing it's
worth noting obviously from our
perspective that was acceptable where it
was and obviously that potentially may
have allowed for some collections the
alternative would be that residents
would have to the carry distance would
be from this from site all the way up to
High Street Garland now I would I would
tend to agree that that is longer than
we would expect it to be however again
because of pot you know in part the
background of the site the fact that
it's in the urban confines the fact that
it is you know surrounded by allocation
um it's whether or not the the quality
of the development and the living
conditions that we're trained for new
residents is acceptable or not so we
consider with the condition
that will require the developer to do
everything they can to provide something
that that is sufficient to avoid this
being effectively unsatisfactory living
accommodation it's also we I we have to
bear in mind on this issue is that the
applicants propose something if this
goes to appeal and this is the only
reason that they haven't got waste
collection sorted out but yet they're
proposing an alternative I'd be
surprised given the fact they're
providing four units of accommodation I
would anticipate that we would we really
struggle to defend that on appeal with
the benefits of providing full dwellings
on the site so that it's it is a
weighing up process if this isn't ideal
but we think the Safeguard of the
condition is going to be sufficient to
set the starting stall for this I do
accept what you're saying that we don't
have the details in front of us at this
point in time but it is a condition is
exactly the process that we would expect
to get these sorts of details in in fact
we're obviously doing it with regards to
Landscaping it is a technical bit of
information that we get in and we do
think it's robust enough to be able to
enforce in the future
thank you councilor Clinton
thank you I know we discussed the state
of the unmade road while we were on the
site visit can you just remind us of um
whose responsibility it is because I am
concerned that the the size and depth of
that lovely pothole that we've just seen
and um the impact of the additional
traffic that will be going down there
um thank you
yes so as mentioned the the there is no
defined ownership of that that road that
runs all the way around and that has was
an issue that was looked at again in the
2016 application so the stretch of road
that's to be used primarily by these
four dwellings or I appreciate there's
the other route that comes out to the
right of the image that you're looking
at
um
but the applicant has now stated that
they are going to following construction
um noting the condition of the road at
the moment and obviously with
construction vehicles there is expected
to be some further deterioration from
construction that's why they are
proposing and again it's it's
safeguarded through through the
condition of the construction management
plan the the stretch from High Street
Garland to the site will be resurfaced
with tarmac obviously the details of
that are going to be linked to the the
hard Landscaping details that we have a
separate condition on which relates to
the area that you can see in the photo
and in terms of ongoing maintenance
after that point that isn't something
that is safeguarded through this
planning application and we wouldn't
that would be going over and above what
the planning legislation can do is
obviously the ownership of that land is
is not is not is not defined
but obviously the current situation with
regards to the condition of that tarmac
is is something that has got to be bear
in mind it is in poor State at the
moment and it is not going to be
worsened by the fact of them resurfacing
part of it it's no worse detriment uh
with the addition of these these four
units once that work has been carried
out
um so again it is a again it's a limit
of the planning con sort of planning
system that we can obviously look at the
red line areas particularly and
obviously we have got this commitment
from the developer that they will they
will carry out and obviously they they
were on the site visit they could hear
residence concerns and they know that
this is a particularly live issue and an
ongoing issue just as it is for a waste
collection and other matters
um I wasn't actually at the site visit
but looking at that and members have
mentioned it it is alongside a bridal
way
um does anybody know how often and that
horses do use it how often
people take their horses along there
because if a horse comes along well
there's a a vehicle about
that's going to be awful
could there be some signage I think what
that's that's one of the things that's
being picked up by by the Landscaping
conditions so it is understood and
that's a point that was raised by the
British Hall society as well as Casey
public rights of way about the need for
signage to identify I think for all
users so not just potentially you know
vehicles and so that will need again it
will need submission which will need to
go to KCC polyrights way to be able to
clear those details again before
occupation of any dwellings
thank you councilman yes thank you chair
um Mrs Livingston might be able to
confirm this but as one of the people
that was at the site meeting when we
highlighted the state of the road the
unmade Road and those potholes
um I got the impression that they were
going to tarmac from The High Street up
and make good the road including what
was to be the bin storage area and those
two parking areas so if you use the
boundary on that plan that we saw that
actually encompasses all those potholes
so that was going to be but it was
beyond that that was an issue and that
was going to be covered by those
residents who back on and have access to
that road was down to them but the main
part from The High Street up and
including that trapezium as you showed I
believe was all going to be made good
I think you've answered your question
has some more cancer every
yeah I just wanted to comment on on the
potential for conflict between horses
and
pedestrians and vehicles I mean we
really are I mean the fact is that if a
horse comes up that Bridal way it's
coming out onto a road whether where
there are potentially Vehicles including
waste lorries and ditto pedestrians
we're talking about introducing a
potential conflict on that very small
piece of land at the access to the
bridal way so I don't really think it's
a material issue the horses have got
nowhere else to go but onto the road
where the cars are once they get over it
thank you for that Council Everett um I
can't see any other sorry can't be
coming back
I just had a very brief extra question
um you mentioned earlier um about the
moving of the bridalway sign
um and needing to get KCC permission to
do that will that be arranged and agreed
before development work begins because
it seems a bit pointless if it's not
so that the Clause that's put in is is
it it could occur
um I think there will need to be a bit
of an understanding of uh as part of the
construction whether or not that signage
needs to move the conditioned trigger is
actually prior to occupation of any
dwelling because what's trying to be
dealt with is
the vehicles using the site for
residential purposes So to avoid it
before any residents move in there and
are going in and out of that that we've
got the sign is sorted out
um obviously again in terms of making
sure there is signage there we obviously
wouldn't want to put signage in that
could be affected via construction but
the construction management plan
um you know is is outlining about the
need to try and make sure that Bridal
way is kept open during construction
it's something again that is is fully
understood by all parties about the need
for that to be the case the question is
it's it's currently the trigger is prior
to occupation of the dwellings but the
details of the signage indeed is is to
be agreed with KCC
um and you know we have got the comments
of cases already that give an indication
of what they would want which will be
which of which have basically be
forwarded onto the applicant already so
they can preempt it and get the
information as quickly as possible
thank you
I don't think I think it's Council
he is Council boring
thank you for noticing me
um in summary I would sort of say there
are too many vaguenesses and loose ends
on it for it to even form something that
would be a valid application there are
too many open ends and they need to be
clarified before we can
treat it as a valid application
that would be my opinion there are just
too many Loose Ends
um
yes I I think as a wall in um
from site visit you know I know not
everybody can be there but what's been
explained tonight I updated yeah
um but I will bring him back
um so the application is is valid in the
sense of the technical side of
validation of providing the relevant
plans for consultation the application
in our view can be determined on the
basis of what we've got subject to those
conditions clearly without the
conditions then you know it's not it
wouldn't be sufficient and we wouldn't
be in a position to determine it but in
terms of what we have and with the
conditions that we're proposing we do
consider that the issues would be would
be dealt with but obviously it's for
members to decide whether or not that's
the that's the case so yeah thank you
Ian
right I'm looking closely now
okay members thank you for that debate
uh I'll put this to you now those in
favor of this application please show
the hand
those against
abstentions
all right that has gone through
six four and five gates so that has
passed
thank you members
okay moving on to agenda item five this
is an update which remember was asked to
bring back for All Saints industrial
estate and All Saints Avenue in Margate
do I have any speakers under 20.1
I have none listed but uh
no okay I'll ask the planning
applications managers who update you on
these plans thank you
foreign
so the application has been reported
back to members following the last
committee uh which
um following a motion
to approve which fell the motion that
was moved was to bring back the
application with potential reason for
refusal next month and to go back to the
applicant of following the debate to
seek a reduction in the number of units
so I'm not intending to go through all
of the slides because you've seen this
twice in in relatively quick succession
but the site is outlined in red
the site's allocated for uh sorry for
his employment land for a mix of
commercial uses it has a previous
approval on the site which approved a
development of light industrial and
um and general industrial which is shown
on this plan which was approved in
uh 20 I'm getting confused the last
application I think about 2016 but it
has expired in the same way as the last
one
um so
the previous proposal that members saw
was for 58 units following the meeting
last last month we spoke to the
applicant and they have proposed the
reduction to remove the two units that
are nearest to the residential dwellings
on the railway Terrace so Railway
Terrace members will recall is the sort
of raised area which is that semi-circle
of properties in detail here so you can
see that the
um there are in the old plan there were
eight units in this area to the right of
the plan the proposal has removed the
two units nearest railway Terrace and
replaced that area with parking so
previously following the first time I
went to planning committee after that
the applicant amended the scheme to
increase the amount of visitor parking
by eight parking spaces with these
changes they've reduced the number of
units by two and added another couple of
parking spaces and reordered the parking
that they had on the site so we've got
10 additional vehicle parking spaces
from the previous
submission in total there was also the
provision that was made at the last
committee for an acoustic fence so this
actually this section which shows the
acoustic fence next to the trees
actually shows the two units that have
now been removed so these units are no
longer part of the development so the
distance has increased between the
Residential Properties and the units and
indeed if if we return to the previous
approval you can see the previous
approval in fact came much closer to
railway Terrace properties than the
newly amended proposal does
so as part of the the provisor members
asked to look at potential reasons for
refusal and so the issues raised
um at the meeting have been assessed by
officers about whether or not any of
them would be raised or having regards
the material planning considerations and
the evidence so section three of the
report looks specifically at this so
looking at
the impact on the properties on Railway
Terrace so
um in terms of specifically the points
that were raised at the last meeting one
of which related to the noise impact
from
um both the actual commercial units but
also the vehicle movements as well as
impact on air quality so this is covered
at 3.3 of the report
and that outlines how the noise a noise
impact assessment and air quality
assessment was submitted with the
application which were assessed by the
council's environmental health Team and
that report concluded that the
development could slightly affect the
acoustic character the site but not such
there's a changing quality of life and
with regards to air quality the report
concluded that the impacts the proposed
development will be below the relevant
air quality objectives meaning the level
of vehicle emissions when modeled would
be within the acceptable range that has
been agreed by the environmental health
Team who raised no objection to the
development subject to specific
conditions with regards to electric
vehicle charging points and hours of of
operation and in addition to that even
with that obviously we have the
inclusion of the acoustic fence which
was put forward by the applicant
following the receipt of amended plans
that remove those two units
um any reason for refusal with regard
the impact on the properties at the
bottom of the image in front of you in
terms of loss of Outlook light and
creation of a sense of enclosure has
also been removed which was a potential
ground of refusal but now that distance
is certainly considered sufficient and
obviously when you compare it to the
2016 application that was approved
indeed it's it's much improved in terms
of the relationship and therefore we
don't consider there to be a Justified
reason for refusal on those grounds
um
now in terms of issues raised on on
visitor parking maneuvering at 0.3.5 of
the report looks at this specifically so
the concerns that members expressed
relate to the ability of vehicles to
maneuver within the new development and
The Wider site so
for the previous report that was in
front of members last month
um outlined how tracking plans have been
submitted by the applicant to
demonstrate how articulated lorries
um actually accessing the neighboring
properties are able to turn currently in
the Triangular section of the site at
the moment
um and and then to be able to leave in a
forward gear in our view given the size
of the individual units that are being
proposed here it's not considered that
there would be the creation of the need
for Arctic sized lorries to actually
access the internal layout of the
development in terms of deliveries the
units are not going to really sustain
any level of deliveries to that extent
and in any event that that was to occur
there wouldn't be a harm to the severe
harm to the highway Network in terms of
free flow of traffic because there is a
turning area that is available on site
without having to impact on All Saints
Avenue in addition no concerns are
raised by KCC with regards to expected
trips and visibility space from that
existing access and indeed the access is
being effectively redone with pedestrian
visibility displays and again is being
fully tarmaced all the way back into the
site and I have got the photos but I'm
sure members can recall and probably
some of you know quite how of a poor
state of repair that current access is
in so again in the absence of any
objection from cases there's a highway
Authority any tangible evidence of an
impact on the highway as a result of the
development it's not considered there's
a Justified ground of refusal on that
and
overall um
in the view of officers with regards to
members concerns
we don't consider that there would be a
Justified reason for refusal with
regards to National or local policy and
effectively
we can't find a reason for refusal
which we could legitimately argue appeal
without being at risk of a full cost
award um it's an allocated site for
employment use we have a previous
consent on there and there are clear
benefits that would weigh in support of
the development and given the specific
reduction in units which members
requested with the SM with the small
increase although I appreciate 10
parking spaces and small but 10 parking
spaces will also make a difference in
addition to the original submission we
recommend uh at 4.1 of the report that
the application subject to all these
amendments should be approved thank you
chair uh thank you Ian yes I do I move
the office's recommendations as you
heard be adopted which is
4.4.1 to be approved the amended
application Council describe please
second second that chair members
conservation
thank you chair I feel with the
reduction units and the additional
parking spaces I can see no further
reason to reject this application
thank you do I see any other speakers
I don't
okay members thank you for that I put
this to you those in favor you've heard
of the report
that was against
any abstentions
that is carried
that's all yeah
thank you for that members uh moving on
now to agenda item 6A application for
approval
which is land at newhane Road Ramsgate
and speaking in favor of this
application is a Miss Amy templin I
believe you're there yes you have three
minutes
chairman members of the committee good
evening and thank you for the
opportunity to speak this evening my
name is Amy Tamplin and I represent the
applicant David Wilson homes I'd like to
thank the plan and officer for their
extensive report and recommendation for
approval I will not repeat the details
of the report rather reiterate and
respond to some of the key points Azure
aware the site is one that already
benefits from outline planning
permission through a hybrid application
of which the development of phase one is
progressing well the application before
you this evening considers the detailed
layout scale appearance and Landscaping
of 117 residential dwellings
this development has been designed to
comply with the parameters set out
within the hybrid especially in terms of
Building height and density this was to
ensure the development was sensitive to
the context in particular the scores
adjacent
concerns were raised by councilor and
parents of children who attend lalam Gap
School in terms of the resultant loss of
privacy and increased noise we work
proactively alongside the planning
officer to ensure this was addressed
upon submission in line with the
building Heights parameter plan the
three-story Apartments were front in
both newham Road and Marlowe Road
however we have made additional
amendments there are now predominantly
two-story apartment blocks with minimal
three-story close to this boundary this
significantly reduces the overlooking
and privacy concerns a landscaping
buffer along this boundary was also
agreed at the Hybrid stage which
enhances the screen and buffer further
another main concern from residence was
noise
a construction management plan
restricting working hours and vehicular
movements will ensure minimal disruption
a noise assessment was submitted at the
Hybrid stage which should provide
reassurance that appropriate mitigation
measures will be implemented
the housing mix both in terms of private
and affordable has been well received by
both the planning and housing officer
and addresses the local needs especially
in terms of the one and two bear
departments all dwellings are supported
by private and communal electric
charging points promoting sustainability
the design also includes a substantial
area of open space which extends the
linear Park in phase one offering a
variety of formal and informal open
space with pedestrian links to The Wider
area incorporating a range of ecological
enhancement and biodiversity Net game
features
throughout the planning process we work
proactively with officers responding to
queries raised and would ask members to
note that there are no objections from
KCC highways the environment agency KCC
drainage nor indeed any of thanet's own
officers overall the application
provides much needed homes within a
sustainable location within the district
and I would urge members to support the
office recommendation in granting
approval this evening thank you uh thank
you Miss templin I will now pass you
over to Emma who will outline
supplication
thank you chairman and this is the
application site
um on the right hand side here so the
oval red line is around the entire
um site that was approved through the
hybrid application last year
um the area shaded at the bottom here is
phase one which is currently under
construction and the area on the right
hand side of this screen is the
application we're considering tonight so
this is phase two of
um of the development
another slide just showing again the
outline of the actual applications so
the proposal was for 117 units within
this area here it's a reserve matters
application so the consideration tonight
is for the layout appearance and
um Landscaping of of the development so
access at this point here has already
been approved along with the principle
of the 117 units in this location
so this is aerial view of the oval site
so Westward is to the north of this
slide you can see Sainsbury's in this
location here
um to the west of newhane road is the
area where phase one has been approved
and is under construction and the
application
um before you is in this location here
so north of layland Gap school and Royal
Harbor
and you can see on this side as well the
existing footpath that runs from New
Home Road through to Jackie Baker's
which is on the right hand side here
so again just another view of the site
so again the application site is in this
location here so this um area is the
Hedge screening along the eastern
boundary of the site with Jackie Bakers
on the right hand side and you can see
Marlow way to the south of the the side
the the site and new Hane Road um on on
the west hand side and again you can see
the existing access into the sides
so these are now some photos of of the
site itself so this is taken from the
the north of the site looking South so
standing close to the existing footpath
that runs through to Jackie Baker so
this is the actual application site here
in the distance you can see the Milo
Academy and you can see Laden Gap school
and so again there's another view there
showing the existing fencing Mark in the
boundary adjacent to newhane Road
and then um
this area here which is the foot pass
you can see on the left hand side the
footprofit runs through to Jackie
Baker's and then this is the the
existing footpath so this forms the
northern boundary of the site and so to
the right hand side here you'll see in a
moment this area is going to be a
landscape linear Park that will form
part of the connection
um of a green Corridor over to um
Jackie Baker's
so just moving south now this is a um
just the uh
the building that's used for the setting
of the units so this area is just a
temporary building so this will go once
the development of phase two commences
so again you can see here this is the
existing avicular axis that will run
into phase two
and we're now on the southern part so
south south of the existing access into
the site again you can just see um the
existing condition of the sites
and again this is now the southern
boundary of the site and again you can
see uh Leyland get to school and Marlow
Academy on the left-hand side here
so this is um to the south of the site
you can see on the right hand side of
this slide is phase one which is under
construction so these are the existing
flat buildings fronting onto newhane
Road
and then again another view of that
there so you have
um you'll see later the actual design of
this development follows the um the
pretty much the design that you can see
within phase one so you have a curved
um flat bill a flat development that
runs around fronting onto the roundabout
and then you can see in the distance
there's some dwellings and again a
closer view of those you can see there's
the style and materials that are used
within the site
and then this is now within Marlow way
so we're to the south of this site with
um Lane and got a score on the left so
you can see the existing boundary
treatment to uranium school which
consists of fencing and Hedgerow
and this is looking from again the south
of the site with the application site
behind us towards Leyland Gap school so
again just um noticing the the existing
boundary treatment that exists and this
is now again to the South with the
application site on the right hand side
now which is um which is screened and
again Leyland gap on the left here and
then just a view showing the existing
boundary of you into Lane and gaps
showing that on the other side of the
boundary is is Open Fields and play
Space serving the school
and then this just shows the again the
application site here this is on the
eastern boundary to the South area of um
Landscaping that will remain as part of
the layout
so um approval has has already been
given for the the principle of the
development and through the hybrid
application parameter plans were
approved so this is a parameter plan for
the land use it shows that there would
be residential development within the
site and to the north of the site would
be the
um a green Corridor in the form of a
linear Park this is also secured through
the legal agreement the requirement of
this linear Park would extend from Hayne
Road on the to the west and all the way
through phase one through phase two and
Connect into Jackie Baker so providing a
wide walking area with play equipment
and lots of different forms of
landscaping
and the plan uh the primary plan also
showed that that any development should
be set back from New Hain road with um
tree planting along the boundary so
there was a requirement for everything
to be set back a minimum of 3.5 meters
with a 3.5 meter
um uh tree screen along here to former
Treeline street that continues along
newhane road and it also required on the
eastern boundary that there would be the
retention and provision of a new
Hedgerow and and planting
this um is the heights parameter plan
that was approved through the hybrid
application so the darker Blue Area
approved development of two and a half
to three stories in height and the hatch
Blue Area approved development of two to
two and a half stories in height so the
main dominant buildings would be
fronting onto the main road and then um
the builders behind it would be slightly
smaller up to two and a half stories in
Heights so in terms of the relationship
with the school which was one of the
concerns that's been raised the
parameter plan did approve up to three
stories in in height wrapping around
that corner with development and looking
towards the the open playing fields of
the school but you'll see later that we
have uh sort amendments to try and
reduce the impact of of the height of
that development opposite the school
so this is a proposed layout plan and
you can see on the left hand side this
was the layout of phase one that has
been approved and as as I said is under
construction
um so this is the the proposal here so
you can see to the north of the site
again is the linear Park
um so through the linear Park there's
lots of
um pedestrian paths to form a walking
area through through the space and
benches to the center of the site
um the path that you saw within the
photo is is in the list this location
here so the north of linear Park so that
forms a main connection into Jackie
Baker's and then there will be these
pedestrian links through the linear Park
that will connect on to that within the
actual site itself I'll just show you
this in a bit more detail so this is to
the north of um the site so again you
can see more detail the linear Park and
then you can see the actual layout so
it's just a Central Access Road running
through the middle a number of different
cul-de-sacs that run off this and
there's a variety of building types so
on along the western boundary these are
flats and then everything within the
site is houses so mixture of detached so
many detached and terrorist units all
two to two and a half stories in height
and then this is the southern part of
the site so again Flats on the western
side and wrapping around the corner
similar to the development opposite in
phase one and then again houses
um of varied types of fronting onto all
the all the um main roads and fronting
also one so Jackie Bakers and the linear
part to the top
um the uh in terms of hard surfs and you
can see that there's a quite a lot of
areas of
um Paving so the pink is Paving the gray
is tarmac and the dark gray is um is
also Paving
um so there's a variety of different
hard surfacing materials you can see in
terms of the setback that the three and
a half meter set back to the front he
just achieved with the tree planting
and there's also areas around the rest
of the site where there's lots of areas
of soft Landscaping
so in terms of the design
um this is a street elevation so I'll
just go around each um side of the site
just showing the street elevations so
this is the site
um the elevation fronting onto newhane
road so these are the flatted
developments of three stories so this
building on the left on the top left
here is the one adjacent to the linear
Park
um and then um these units here are on
the bottom are to the right hand side of
the axis and this one here is to the
left-hand side of the axis you can see
they're all very similar in style again
similar to the buildings within phase
two they're all brick they have some
render some
um clad in the windows are set in
reveals they're quite large openings and
they're quite vertical emphasis quite
staggered in the um in the elevation
so this is now wrapping around so facing
onto Marlow way so this is the area that
was amended so this three-story building
wrapped entirely around with this area
here fronting onto the field so this
this has now been amended so that the
three-story element that was here has
been shifted to the other side and then
this um two-story element that was on
the other side has been moved here in
order to reduce overlooking towards the
skull
and then you can see on the bottom hand
side bottom of this slide is the
remainder of the properties that front
onto Marlow way so there's not too many
it's quite a lot of space in there are
only two stories in height
um
and then this one fronts onto Jackie
Baker's so again you could just see a
variety of different building styles
it's a mixture of buff and red brick two
different roof tiles and as mentioned
there would be cladding and some render
as well within that
and then this is the elevation that
fronts on to the linear Park
um so again it will have um quite a good
Frontage onto linear Parts there'll be
lots of natural surveillance again this
was amended to introduce a few more
materials so we've got the cladding on
the two end elements and then on the
bottom side here again you see the flat
building that would be on the corner so
a bit of a landmark building that turns
a corner um onto linear Park
um so in terms of parking there's two
parking spaces per dwelling one parking
space for each flat and
um around 30
um 30 or so visitor parking spaces
within the site as well so there's no
concerns from Highway highways that
they're quite happy with the Turning
provision and the parking provision
within the site
um in terms of ecology because that was
another issue that was raised
um that was mainly dealt with at the
outline stage and reports were submitted
through this application that it's
proposed there would be ecological
enhancements mainly within the linear
Park area but within the development
itself there's also going to be a range
of different things including bats and
bird boxes Swift bricks um orchestral
boxes and Hedgehog fencing so um KCC are
quite happy with that there was there's
still a requirement for a submission to
come in under the outline
um condition but otherwise they're quite
happy there's no impact on ecology
in terms of the concerns to do with the
school so the score again is this in
south of the site here
there's a distance of 22 meters between
the front elevation of the closest
dwelling and the site boundary of the
school
um and then you can see that beyond that
are the fields and some hard surfaced
and playing areas so it's an additional
eight meters to the hard surface playing
area given that distance
um given the fact the parameter plan has
approved up to three story in this
location given the fact that there's
Hedgerow and fencing along the boundary
that exceeds two meters in height it is
considered that the impacts on on
privacy within the school is acceptable
also within phase one that similar
relationship has already been approved
in terms of the noise
um that was dealt with through the
outline application with a noise
assessment submitted and mitication
mitigation has been secured that deals
with any impact in terms of children
from the school from construction noise
so just a quick I'll just quickly scan
through these because they were mainly
showing through the street Innovations
but again these are just the views of
the different
um flat blocks along the front so these
are all the Francis ones onto newhane
Road
um so at one point we did seek
amendments to the side innovation of the
flat blocks either side of the Central
Access into the site because it was
quite a blank elevation so we've now had
um enlarged Windows including additional
features introduced to create more of a
dual Frontage so that was an amendment
that that has improved the design
um sorry just still flicking through
some so that again that was so this is
the element that was
um amended to address the impact on the
school so this is the two-store element
that's been shifted so you can see on
the floor plan here that's garages at
ground floor level with only one flat oh
sorry we've only one flat uh only one
flat above it and then nothing above
that so that's just showing that a
change
and then this is just showing material
so again variety of materials within the
site and then just quickly show you the
Landscaping plan so these are broken up
into three slides you can see the tree
tree-lined um Street and on the Frontage
here with um other Hedgerow planting and
then you can see again the linear Park
so there's a real range of planting
within the part you've got some
um tree area creating like an orchard
area in this location you've got the
benches in the middle this is actually
immunity space it would be like Play
space for children and then there's lots
of areas of
um Wildflower growth
um and on there and you can again you
can see all the footpath connections so
it it is a so it's previously been
approved for for the number of units
it's considered that the design and
layout is acceptable there's not going
to be any significant harm in our um in
our view to the school or any
surrounding occupiers and the designers
in keeping with the phase one that's
already underway and so it is
recommended for approval thank you uh
thank you Emma for your detailed report
they're very interesting I moved office
recommendation which is for approval
good to council sharp please second yes
second act chair thank you members over
to councilor Ghana
thank you thank you thank you for the
for running through the report I'm going
to start with the um positives
because there are some here I mean I
like the um the linear Park that looks
really
really good it'll be a nice lot of trees
there nice Orchard
that's really good the other positive is
I'm I mean I I called this in because I
wanted to we haven't actually had an
opportunity
for no thought of anybody but ourselves
to discuss any of the Hayne Road
developments uh planning committee so I
thought it would be a good opportunity
to do so and I'm glad I did because it
seems to have led to a slight change in
the design so that there is less
overlooking onto the school I'm still
not sure about the other overlooking
um
well no it's not necessarily A
consideration for this
for for this particular application but
I must say every time I drive out or
back into into thanet along the Hayne
Road it fills me with more and more
dread is always a word I mean often when
we look at designs of buildings we think
well they they always look a lot better
than what they're going to look when
they're built
um and if if they're
the the designs of some of these
buildings just
look particularly Bland and
awful to me but I know that's not
necessarily a planning consideration so
I'll move on to
what I really wanted to or what some of
the items that I wanted to talk about
for the reasons I called this in which
was around the landscape inside as I
said that park looks good but reading
through the report I know there was a
you met you mentioned there was an
ecological design strategy outline
when this was approved outline
um proposing a number of
ecological enhancements which as I can
reading through it seems they've been
dumbed down at this stage because the
the latest version of the strategy is
reduced the number of back boxes on site
from 50 to 20. it's reduced the number
of Swift bricks
from 40 to 20
and
um you mentioned Kestrel boxes well
there is now just one
reduced from two
um
and I think a major concern of mine
looking at that plan which I hadn't
really realized before
lovely park but there's eight there
aren't any Gardens as far as I can see
there's no all of those houses they want
to go and play outside they have to go
up the road to the park there's no
outside Green Space do any of the houses
and correct me if I'm wrong if there is
then then fair enough it's all around
the edge which I don't think is um
is particularly conducive to to healthy
living
there are two cast parking spaces for
each one so
I am so so I do have those concerns I've
realized I did want to have a number of
other concerns about the application
which for which I wanted to call this in
but I realized that we can't discuss or
they can't be considered because they've
already been approved outline
um and a major one of those would have
been relating to the um sewage and um
water supply to the site but that's
their Microsoft I don't know if you can
maybe come back and
confirm around the ecological design
strategy changes
thank you thank you Council
um
I mean in terms of the ecological
impacts yeah there was a condition on
the outline that required them to submit
a detailed assessment showing the
ecological enhancements so that that has
come in but it hasn't been fully
assessed by um KCC biodiversity which is
why we've reapplied the condition onto
this application because they've said
that they will deal with it through the
condition stage rather than through this
application
um so that condition has been reapplied
I'm not actually sure I I know the
answer in terms of that because in terms
of the difference between what was in
the strategy and what they're now
proposing unfortunately I don't I didn't
I don't have a list of what was in the
strategy in terms of what they offered
but in terms of what the offers through
this I don't believe KCC have actually
raised any concerns with the principle
of the number of things I've provided
through the for the enhancements
um but again it really is going to be
dealt with through condition more than
anything so it's not it's not something
that we could look at you know objecting
to the application for because it is all
been dealt with through the condition
stage
um but I mean there's a lot as you as
you saw from the Landscaping plan there
is a lot of different forms of
landscaping within that area and it's
not just all going to be grass it's lots
of different areas of planting
wildflowers trees lots of different
things so there will be lots of
ecological enhancements compared to
what's there at the moment that is just
an open air of grass and lots of tree
planting around the boundaries
um to the west and the East additional
Hedgerow so there's gonna be a lot of
additional plants within this site
compared to what's there now even though
it's being developed so I do think
overall there is there is going to be
enhancements um I mean in terms of the
open space that you mentioned for the
flats that was something that was raised
during the application because yes we're
always Keen to see
um private Dorset play space for Flats
um and it is quite limited I agree with
you but what we've looked at is the fact
that these Flats um to the north here
and in this area here are all actually
one bed units so in terms of the policy
we couldn't actually request that they
they provide Dorset play Space because
they're not going to be family units so
the only um two bed units are in this
curved building at the bottom here and
that area has been amended so that was
smaller originally when the application
came in and then amended it by
reconfiguring the um parking area to the
rear to enlarge that space
um and we're now you know we don't have
any space standards for Dorset play
Space we just have to judge it on
whether we think the space is usable and
accessible and suitable for the number
of units
um and in that central location accessed
directly from the rear of the building
we feel that that probably is large
enough to serve serve that building so
in terms of daughter play space that
there is considered to be adequate
provision all of the houses clearly have
Gardens to the rear I mean to the north
here they have provided
um another space between the buildings
but again this is these are all one bed
so they don't have to have provided it
they just have provided it just to
provide an area for that building and
then in this location here there's
another
um area to the rear there so but neither
of those actually are acquired by policy
to have been provided
uh thank you come back so I just wanted
to cover yeah thank you thanks for that
yeah no I agree that actually that the
the trees All Around The Edge on that
Park are a good ecological enhancement I
must have misunderstood looking at that
the the number of Gardens there because
I can't see
they're not shown in green anyway next
to the houses
but if there are a number of Gardens and
yeah fair enough and just one other
question sorry which is unrelated to
what I said but but what I commented on
earlier but the um the access to the
site
um am I right in assuming that the the
the the
only way a car can drive onto that site
is driving up the road from Sainsbury's
so if you're if you're driving home from
out of thanet you have to go past that
entrance up to Sainsbury's around the
roundabout and back to go in as a matter
of information
yep
yes um I'll just go back to the photo of
the access
and not that one there so that's the
that is the existing access so yes you
um I believe there's signs here I think
apart there and turned out from there so
yeah there's signs they're saying that
you have to turn left early so yeah if
you were coming from the south you
couldn't turn into this because the way
it's been designed you wouldn't be able
to swing around in it so you would have
to go back up to the roundabout round
again and turn in to yeah avoid Vehicles
turning across this road that is
obviously quite a heavy heavily used
road and could cause
um accidents if you're trying to turn in
and the cars coming on quite fast so
yeah it is a you'd have to turn out
uh thank you very much Brendan
thank you um my comments are actually uh
in line with what councilor Garner has
already already said I do despair at the
lack of imagination on the architectural
design of some of our Flats I know we
can't turn it down on that score but I
will say it
um I wanted to ask though about the um
the the garden space the the Green Space
a little bit more about
um who and how will we ensure that the
plantings in that space are enabled to
take and take root develop who will be
looking after it and that doesn't
actually appear to be any children's
play I know you said children can play
there but it doesn't actually appear to
be any children's play facilities now I
know that there is a playground in
Jackie Bakers but that is not quite
um that close to to where the these
properties are you've got to cross
Jackie Bakers and everything like that
so it's really about the maintenance the
long-term maintenance of this in space
and The Children's Place facilities
thank you Emma can you answer that
um well a Landscape Management plan
would have been put on the um outline
application and so that then requires
them to set up a management company that
would look after the open space
um so we would require details of that
to come in so that we can understand
who's going to be managing it but
usually the setup an association pay
money in from the residence and then
that management company would maintain
the open space in accordance with the
Landscape Management plan
in terms of actual play provision
because it's part of a larger site again
that was considered as part of the the
original scheme where the play provision
would be so on this slide here on the
left of this slide
um you'll see that there's a much larger
play area within the linear part to the
West so that all fell within phase one
so there's a quite a large player that
obviously will be easily accessible from
phase two because they would just need
to cross the road and continue the path
along to get to that play space and
there's also going to be
um a lap I believe within phase three to
the north so there just wasn't a
requirement for obviously we have to
look at the ovalsight area and through
um policy gio4 we look at the
requirement for play provision and
there's a set um space standard for a
quick play and areas of immediate space
and so through that application with we
require them to achieve a certain
minimum size for that so that was all
dealt with through that and then we
would have an open space specification
policy condition as well that would set
out where all of that's going to be
within the overall site so within this
particular linear Park there's not
um there's not actual play provision but
yes there is play provision in Jackie
Baker's and then there's play provision
on the western linear Park and there
will be other smaller areas of play
Within phase three as well
uh thank you councilor bayford
and I personally feel that it's an
excellent plan I think that there's a
lovely variety of properties not no
design is is to everyone's taste but
people need homes 117 homes and this
case is for all
all types of people all members of
society uh I think with the parking and
the soft Landscaping there is little to
disapprove of thank you uh thank you for
that councilman yes thank you chair
um I tend to agree with councilor
garnering I'm slightly disappointed that
the bird boxes have been reduced in the
number they have uh I'm also concerned
with the Landscaping uh there's mention
of trees and we know that we've had
trees planted recently that that have
been two small saplings and take a long
time to grow in the strategy there has
it been decided that there will be
mature trees that are being planted so
that it gives that sense of greenery
straight away and also Crossing Hayne
Road
um what what has the plan put in for
crossing points because obviously we
know that Hayne Road is a very busy road
there's no underpass going across that
with all those number of houses there's
been lots of children going through in
the throwing or is there any Implement
any consideration for uh foot Bridges to
cross that because again with all those
houses there and the number of traffic
going through there it's going to be a
hazard I just wondered if that had been
considered thank you chair Emma can you
answer that one
um I'm just sorry I just gave 3T the
Landscaping plan
um
foreign
plan for the site and you can see
there's a I don't know if you can see
it's quite small but there's a key on
the right hand side
um which shows the type of planting
that's going to be placed within the
site so I don't know if you can see in
this area here there's different size
trees
um so it is showing that there would be
larger trees and smaller trees and a
variety of different size trees within
the site so they wouldn't all just be
tiny sapling trees and there would be
some larger ones within the main
immunity space
um and then
yeah there is a variety as you can see
well you can't really see but there's a
variety of different forms of planting
um that's using this key all the way
along the boundaries and these trees in
this location here were the orchard
planting trees so there's different
species different sizes
um they'd all be required to be planted
through condition obviously this area is
would be retained as the linear park
because it's required under the legal
agreement so there wouldn't be any you
know potential future that that would be
developed at all because there's a
requirement for that to be provided and
maintained as a linear Park
um in terms of what you've mentioned in
terms of the actual Crossing
um
kind of successfully vamped whilst I was
finding the relevant plan so bear with
me one second members I'll just present
hopefully you can see
um so
um sorry let me just get get rid of all
the stuff on the side
um so what you're seeing here is is the
plan from the outline application so
that on the left hand side of the
dwellings that were approved under phase
one the
uh the access that was was talked about
in terms of uh the the the roundabout is
is here and which goes down towards the
model Academy and then going up here
this is the existing Vector access that
we looked at what you can see is around
where the linear Park is
where the crossing point is going to be
so if I zoom right in you can see where
the crossing point is going to be so
it's literally the the whole principle
behind the original outline application
and I'm actually going back to the 2011
outline application was to try and
provide the linear park with a crossing
point in between through from Jackie
Bakers all the way around to the
Westwood Village Development which is
the 900 houses obviously the Toby
carvery which was approved by members um
a number of years ago so this the
crossing point was considered to be
appropriate in that location to join the
two Park areas
thank you Council can I just come back
to that's a a an ordinary pedestrian
Crossing with lights and crossing point
not Footbridge or anything like that no
it's it's lights yeah it's a it's a
toucan Crossing so with a number of
houses vehicles and what we've got so
far that's going to be gridlocked
I don't think
just to come back on that I mean the so
the outline application obviously looked
at
um traffic flows from this development
looking at the existing road because
obviously when that road went in
originally it was obviously to serve the
development either side as it was
originally granted for employment land
um years and years ago so it has the
road width as a local distributor
standard Road
um you know is in is in place for the
purpose of the amount of vehicles that
are going to be going through there it
is understood obviously that the
concerns would be that obviously depends
on how often those lights are used in
terms of how Stuff stops is coming out
of the district obviously the Hayne Road
is one part of how the district is
proposing to develop and obviously there
is the the thanet in a circuit which is
proposing to provide for the whole
district with the inner Route Around to
ensure that you're not just relying on
one Corridor to get from Ramsgate to to
broadstairs in this instance but for the
the detail here it's it's fundamentally
it's about the provision of obviously
safe pedestrian parking and obviously it
has been something that highways looked
at with the outline and the original
uh thank you Council wing
yeah I understand it was business and
Commercial and then it became
residential and I'm not quite sure the
reasons why that happened but and and
the score would have been put there in
the first instant uh based on it being
business and Commercial which maybe
wouldn't have seen this intensity of
development going in
I've got a number of concerns the
crossing point really worries me that
road is already really really really
gridlocked at certain points of the day
so a bridge over the top would help
alleviate that this is certainly going
to make it worse it's a road I have to
use quite regularly I try to avoid it I
I I have concerns about about the
reduction in some of the the the various
bird boxes uh we're taking away a great
a great big area that would have been a
huge habitat and you often see kestrels
up there at present they'll disappear
uh I have huge concerns about the
Aftercare of of the uh the green spaces
which look look good if you go further
into Westwood cross and you look at some
of the developments up there the trees
are either dead or dying because there
is no Aftercare so I've got no real
confidence in in those trees or those
areas being being maintained going into
the future so there will be a net loss
of of a of a diverse area and the other
thing I'd like to say is uh I I mean we
we're now encouraged to ask questions
about southern water because we we don't
ask them for a general all-encompassing
report on how water usage and waste is
going to be so and we're covering an
area which was previously porous with
quite a lot of tarmac and cement which
is not porous it's a block Paving porous
so are we trying to encourage as much of
the hard surfaces that are put there to
be as porous as they possibly can given
they're not going to be as porous as
grassland off agricultural land to help
alleviate some of those
terrible problems we have with with our
waste water
I think it helped swing Emma
um yes in terms of the the drainage the
pink areas are um Paving areas that
would be porous
um so we've got the tarmac and then I
believe the areas that are dark gray
aren't porous
um for in terms of the actual drainage
that there would be
um attenuation Basin within the linear
Park area so all of the water is is
looking to be um drained into the linear
Park
um so
yeah in terms of yeah in terms of the
areas that are policies say the pink
areas but everything is looking to drain
that direction
if that's okay
um so just in terms of the crossing
point
um the decision about where the crossing
point is was dealt with the outline so
in terms of that that was obviously as
was sharing was the outline application
so that's not a matter for consideration
this this is just looking at the
detailed
um layout specifically
um on this on this site
um just as an additional point with
regards to the drainage obviously we
have consulted with KCC
um surface Auto drainage team
specifically looking again it's similar
to the Landscaping the open spacing so
much that there's a strategy that was in
place at the outline and it's ensuring
compliance with that and that includes
the standard work about runoff rates
absorption rates to ensure you don't
have standing water in your attorney
either public safety issues or indeed
how you know how that serviceable
discharges again this a lot of the site
is actually covered by garden areas and
obviously whilst we can't control
they're not all you know put patio down
or whatever you know whatever it is that
may affect the runoff rate
um again the principles behind the
development are sound in terms of
ensuring there isn't surface water
drainage issues on the site I just did
want to come back on the Landscaping
point I know that this is a a concern of
members and it's something that has been
raised a number of times by this
committee
and you know we are aware of the fact
that there have been situations where
development that has been going on you
know in if we're talking about Westward
cross for a significant number of years
um where uh Aftercare wasn't put in um
the provision wasn't put in adequately
um we I think certainly recognized that
and it's certainly in the sense of the
Landscape Management stuff that we get
in much more rigorous applied to that
specifically obviously the council has
employed
um you know a a particular officer in
the planning team who's working across
including the work after development's
being commenced and we have a number of
breach condition notices served on
developments where they haven't put
their Landscaping in at the moment
um and obviously in the future it's
still
um there is obviously a role that's
that's going to be filled for for a tree
officer which will hopefully bring all
this together with the biodiversity work
as well we have more and more
developments that have either had
consent for a while or they've been in
place in the plan for a while coming
forward and therefore
um as a planning department we need to
be aware of that and the need to make
sure adequate enforcement is in place
for elements such as this especially
when a lot of work has gone into the
Landscaping from all parties on this
site and we need to ensure that it is
delivered adequately
um thank you thank you could I just ask
where the social housing is and are
there any particular properties that are
designated for disability housing
yep
um the affordable is the air is marked
with a red star so it's there's quite a
large number of one bed units on this
side so
um
whilst we'd usually be looking for a mix
of affordable in this case there is a
higher number of one bed than we would
usually
um expect through the policy however
it's town center and we have a really
high knee for one bed units our greatest
need is for the one bed units
um our the housing team have been
consulted and are happy with the
provision so and in terms of the other
phases on the other phases there's a
different mix so each phase is obviously
putting forward a mix and there was
there was a fewer one bed units on phase
one that were affordable so so yes in
terms of this it's it's so it's these
top two blocks these three blocks here
and then if you can see there's two
houses within the center of the site as
well that are also affordable in terms
of
um
like well accessible units in wheelchair
we we have the policy that requires the
um provision the 10 um 10 of the units
to be accessible units and then of the
affordable for I think it's five percent
to be the wheelchair units so and no
complying with that so the compliant
with the policy requirements for
accessible units and all of the units as
well as meeting the space standards as
well set out with within the policy
thank you
that's right
um I know that this this development has
got its permission and it's too late for
this one but I'm a bit disappointed that
we've got a big opportunity here with
all the new developments that are coming
on there's no mention of all the the
high-tech
all singing or dancing saving water the
green roofs and all that kind of thing
uh smart water butts and Planters and I
think maybe for the future uh perhaps we
should look look at that for new
developments there's been a club as a
step forward with climate change
point taken I think quite taken there
thank you Council right Council towning
yeah hi
thank you
um
Coastal War raised a very important
point about the actual Crossing
now that Crossing was approved
additionally as you said is we're back
in 2011.
on the on the previous on the original
application subsequently in the outline
that was approved last year it was it
was approved in that location when
looking at the most up-to-date
information at that point well if you
look at what's happening around us our
environment with regards to traffic and
people coming into the era has grown
substantially
and if we if we can't revisit that I
know we're not here to talk about that
but we ought to go back to the to the
developer but they are a very good
developer I am aware of them and revisit
that
um uh site uh it's just consider uh
maybe a walk over or something like that
because it it is all about safety for
our children and and people that it will
be going up and down the shops are down
the road you know uh so people will be
using that area quite extensively
the other the other point is about
goes to wig raised about uh porous areas
well in southern water I like Southern
water
they're good people with my books they
help the uh our communities
and they have um
well you might laugh because you don't
like them
um but they they have created a water
bot
that has two Chambers
the top chamber seeps into the bottom
chamber
and and when that bottom chamber fills
up the top chamber finishes that fills
up and then what happens is the bottom
chamber gradually disposes off that
water into the land so it stops the
flooding
of our systems that eventually causes
problems of discharges into the sea and
maybe that should be a something that
the developers should look at
and discuss that with them possibly to
provide those butts and I don't think
they'll cost a lot of money and that
should be an option that should be taken
on board maybe not now but for the
future thank you thanks for that Council
town in just just on the
um the the vehicle Point um so in the
2000 the application from uh well uh
last year was actually the year before
is when it came in but it was approved
last year
um that was accompanied by an
environmental impact assessment which
included as part of the information uh
various
um highways work including uh transport
assessment as well as a various safety
audits so in terms of looking
specifically at the projected growth in
the planet local plan to 2031 including
all the houses included modeling vehicle
trips across this site on the basis of
that future growth so in terms of both
safety and in terms of movements and the
impact of the development we do consider
that it was it was assessed rigorously
under that outline application with
regards to Future measures that could be
put in with regards to surface water
drainage it is obviously something that
we are continually getting updates from
KCC Suds team about what they may except
as part of strategies on housing sites
that obviously can develop as things go
on primarily obviously the aim is to try
and get as much permeable surface Paving
in as possible and also having either
um you know actual sort of effectively
the the sort of underground storage
facilities or indeed attenuation basins
if you can if you can get it as well to
all in the surf all in the aim of trying
to reduce surface or drainage flow but
it's technology is improving and
obviously we'll continue to look at what
comes in from from applicants
okay last one consecration
um I just wanted to make a comment on
the Footbridge again or on the crossing
I'm I'm kind of conflicted because I
actually do agree that um this is going
to cause uh considerable traffic delays
particularly at busy times but a
Footbridge isn't actually a very
disabled or pushed share friendly either
so
um I'm kind of inclined to stick with
the crossing and hope it works
thank you for that okay members uh so
draw a line under there I think again
good debate um we put this to you
um this is for approval those in favor
could they please show
those against
any abstentions
thank you members that's being carried
unfortunately
thank you members
okay uh agenda item 6B which is another
54 Stone Road broadstairs
um speaking against this application is
Mrs Anita Goddard
are you there
uh sorry to have kept you no not at all
okay you have three minutes thank you
very much for allowing me to speak
um I'm strongly objecting to the second
application for the change of the
Bungalow 54 Stone Road into a two-story
townhouse we objected I think it was
about September last year but it was
passed by thanet District Council on the
condition that the front brick Flint
wall was maintained because the Builder
had broken the entire Flint wall of uh
54 Stone Road on the side and uh prior
to the use of the ground floor of this
new two-story townhouse uh 1.8 meter
privacy screen had to be erected and
maintained and they had to have frosted
glass to prevent our us being overlooked
however now he's trying to push the
rules further and he has made the entire
a ground floor Terrace the full width of
the property this has resulted in this
Pro the extension coming to within
500 centimeters from our house so it's
less than a meter away
from our house his his extension he's
also made the first floor balcony the
entire width of the property again
within 500 centimeters from our boundary
wall and uh it is this will cause I I
can see a complete loss of light to us
and our privacy we will be totally
overlooked also there's increased depth
and height of his proposed construction
as I said will block any light coming
into our patio which we sit on very
often we've got two young children and
we're a little bit concerned that the
overhang will be encroaching onto our
house
so there are lots of concerns he extends
his house and then he moves on and we
are left to deal with these problems
which
are
are unacceptable really it will be
horrific for us we will have no light
and we will have will be overlooked
thank you thank you very much
um
who will give the report
thank you chair
so this is number 54 Stone Road outlined
in red
and the application is for two-story
front and rear extension some roof
lights a front porch the rear balcony
that's been mentioned and alterations to
fenestration and external materials off
the property and as has been mentioned
there was an application approved to
extend the property and convert it to a
two-story dwelling
that came before members in September
last year so some members may recall
that application
so this is the application site here on
this aerial image
and this is a enough of you of it here
so you can see this is number 56a
and 56 here and this is number 52a and
you can see there's a variety of
property Styles and scales of properties
within surrounding area
so looking at some photographs of the
site so this is the application property
here
excuse me this is number 56 a which is
so you can see is two-story
and again this is 52a again a two-story
property
so looking again this is 52 I and you
can see beyond that is another two-story
property
there
and looking the other way 56a is here to
story and again
um a largest property
at number 56 to that side as well so
this is just a view Looking Down Stone
roads you can see the variety of styles
within the area and the variety of
heights and different materials that are
found in the air so it is quite a varied
area
and again this is not such a good view
but it's kind of looking the other way
down Stone Road so you have number 54
here
52a and 52
um going beyond that but again it shows
the variety of materials and scales of
properties
and this is standing in the rear Garden
of number 54 so the application site
so 52 sorry 56a is now on your on the
right of the side here and this is
number 52 and you can see they are
bigger than the current property that
we've got at number 54. at the moment
and so this is looking at number 54 here
and the relationship between
um with number 50
6A so hip to get my numbers in order so
you can see it is there is a gap between
the properties and number 56a is higher
um then obviously the Bungalow of Chalet
Bungalow at the present time and this is
looking at the other neighbors neighbors
the number 52a this is the edge of
number 54 so you can see there is an
existing Gap and number 54 2A is a quite
a large property in comparison to number
54.
and this is looking back towards
um
the properties in eastern Esplanade and
there is a
the land levels do slope down from Stone
Road towards the Eastern Esplanade so
there is a difference in height
between the two but the different
properties in eastern es blade are some
sort of 30 odd meters away from the rear
boundaries of the actual house flank
rear flank walls of
properties in Stone Road as generally
so this is existing block plan so that's
number 56a that we just saw and 52a and
this is existing Shelley bungalow on
number 54.
so this is a proposed block plan
you will note the garage remains in
place but it becomes a much more sort of
rectangular property
rather than the sort of square form that
we had before
so this is existing front elevation this
is where we saw out of the front garage
the two sort of bay windows projecting
there
and this becomes the front elevation as
proposed to the garage as I say is
retained and we have it come becomes
two-story but away from number 56 a
this is existing North elevation side
elevation so this front's on to 56a
and this is a proposed side elevation
to that facing onto 56a this is the
other side as existing
and a proposed side elevation
and you can see that yes this the
two-story elements coming in the
existing rear elevation so this is the
main property this is the rear of the
garage
and again the same view as proposed so
you can see there is the rear
um balcony here
there is the garage to the rear here and
it is considered
that there would be no overlooking from
the balcony towards properties in
eastern Esplanade given the 30
meter distance between the two and it is
considered given the set in from the two
sides of the site that there would not
be issued and from overlooking to those
properties on either side so 52a and 56a
but there would be an option if members
felt thought it appropriate to perhaps
put some privacy screens to the sides of
that balcony but we have not suggested
it as a condition at the present time
so we have the existing roof plan here
and we do have the proposery of plans as
I say it becomes obviously two-story
been a much more rectangular
property so this existing ground floor
of the property so it's single story The
Garage again here
and this is the proposed first floor so
we have the Terrace that's been referred
to here
uh the garage stays in place we have
home offices Lounge
a Peloton room and a dining room
kitchens sort of
um
standard living accommodation at this
level
and then we have the bedrooms on the
first floor and that's the balcony that
you've seen on the elevations here the
master bedroom and the two further
bedrooms to the front
so this is the existing Street Scene so
you can see
what we've seen in the photographs
previously
that number 54 is maybe odds slightly
with this part of Stone Road in that
it's smaller and it is a shallow
Bungalow but given the variety
of what's around it it is what it is
but this is a pro street scene so it
will become higher than it is but it
actually rises from 6.2 meters in height
to the ridge to 7.3 meters
and it is
comparable if not slightly lower than
the houses on either side of it
and the yellow line you sort of orange
yellow line that you can see dotted
around whilst the height and bulk of the
previous extension that members approved
in last September just to give you an
idea
and just to give you an idea of that
this is what was approved at the front
elevation of in 20 uh 22 in September
last year
so
officers are
consider that given the variety and
scale and materials within the um
this area's Stone Road it is not
considered that the design or would look
out of keeping or the materials proposed
which is a render and cladding into some
elements as you can see from this sorry
the wrong elevation sorry
go back to
this front elevation so it's render and
cladding so it's a material that's found
in the surrounding area
it isn't considered that there is a
impact on residential amenities of
surrounding occupiers and it would
provide a good standard of accommodation
for future occupiers
and there are no Highway issues
considered with it the rear wall has
been mentioned and it is understood and
proposed that the rear wall the Flint
wall will be um
put back
in that area so the officer
recommendation is for approval
thank you members uh thank you and we're
all you heard it is uh recommended for
approval
um I move the opposite of recommendation
I could catch the shrub please second
second that chair thank you members
councilor over it
yeah I've decided I don't see anything
wrong with it but I'd just like some
clarification really as to the
separation distance between the the the
building as it is and the neighboring
properties because the um
objector seemed to think it was
considerably closer to their property
than the
um than what we're seeing on the screen
would suggest so can we just be clear
all the separation distances are
I'll ask Annabelle if she can come back
apologies I will have to measure them
for bear with me
um I I've walked out cancer Moore while
we're waiting to get some off yes thank
you chair
um looking at the application there are
a few conditions
um that were put in place on the
previous one have they been complied
with because it's mentioned that the
Flint wall was taken down has it been
put back
um because obviously I can see from the
Boston Society they raised that
um obviously
um again as Council Everett has said I'm
concerned about the proximity of the
neighbors uh boundary and also I think
that with that rear extension there
should be a condition they should be
screening to prevent overlooking because
that's quite a large rear um first floor
balcony area handkerchief thank you
um yes you can yes
sorry just whilst we're getting
measurements one thing if I can come
back just on the balcony point and I'm
I'm going to quickly
um ask Annabelle to go to the um the
slide that shows the floor plan of first
floor
okay
um
so the balcony itself which is obviously
at the top of the image there that
doesn't protrude out from the back of
the property so what you're seeing there
is that the roof of that Gable comes
over the balcony so what that's
physically restricting is views either
side and obviously what we'd normally do
with privacy screens if you've got a
balcony that's over hangers you put
previously screens on these days you
can't just turn to a left and right and
see into a neighbor's Garden so because
of that all the views are being
channeled down the garden and as animal
mentioned the distance there is is
significant to the properties on Eastern
Escalade so in terms of any additional
restrictions that could be put on it's
not considered that there's any harm to
mitigate with regards to additional
restrictions on say the area of that
balcony so you could constrain the width
of it by putting privacy screens up sort
of within the sort of overall scale of
the property and within that balcony
area but at the moment you can't turn
left and right and see you've got an
angled view down and a view towards the
sea so there isn't considered to be a
need for further the mitigation on on
that side of things
um
I'm going to have to just have a quick
investigation with us the Flint wall
unless
Annabelle knows the answer off the top
of her head but I'll I will come back on
that and I will defer for the
measurements
now
okay sorry in terms of the measurements
to number 56a it's existing is 3.5
meters and the proposed is exactly the
same it doesn't move any closer to
number 56a
thank you
customer
yes thank you chair
um yeah I I take on board what Mr
Livingston said about the balcony with
the the roof side coming down but if you
go to the edge of the balcony you can
look over
you can look into that Garden you're not
you're not back in the building you're
coming up to the balcony looking out and
you can see into both Gardens
the principle behind it in terms of
overlooking obviously you've got
rear-facing windows at first floor in
most Residential Properties you could
open your window turn to the left turn
to the right and look into your
neighbor's Garden
what we're trying to do is create a
situation where you're not creating
prolonged overlooking you know we can't
stop human behavior potentially but at
the same time it's all about integrating
into the design to ensure you're not
resulting in a you know a flat roof area
where people are sitting out on and they
literally are sitting down and looking
left and right so by virtue of having
that
um you know having actually the Gable
and this inset within the Gable means if
you're on that balcony you're not able
to look directly one way or another so
what the aim of this is trying to do is
like first floor windows at the back
pointing towards the rear the first five
meters at the rear of your property is
the most private because that's the view
that you're not getting from those first
floor windows so again this doesn't make
the situation
um you know any worse than a normal
two-story relationship because of where
the balcony is in that property and how
it how it has been designed
okay
um Mrs garad I'm afraid I can't bring
you back
no I'm sorry
no I can't I'm sorry
I've come back to council over it did
you get the answer
you asked well I understand that there's
a three and a half meters separation
distance to the boundary so we're
talking about
52i are we what we're talking about 54.
I'll get one numbers right
maybe we can I don't know whether we're
going to measure both properties right
and be able to tell you obviously the
main thing on
um the the relationship with 56 A's the
one to the left is obviously
um if Annabelle could skip back to the
existing block plan you can see that the
garage position isn't changing in terms
of the actual single story element so
that relationship is
um you know it's effectively the the
same in terms of they've they've got
there's something on the boundary at the
moment and there's going to be something
on the boundary with the with the the
change to the garage that's that's there
at the moment
why we're looking I'll come to Council
of aphid
reasonable for there to be an extension
in this class but
and and I think this was accepted
eventually but by the residents but it
I'm I'm sure that this property shows
the extension has moved closer to the
other property and like cancer I'm
totally confused by the by the diagram
because
it looks like a big space but I can't
I I thought it
I thought it was much an error
while we're checking still I believe I
will come back to counselor more uh yes
chair um it's all very well measuring
off a plan but we're not actually
looking at the building in situ now so
we could say that the plan says that
it's three meters but we actually look
at the building on in face value and you
might find that it's even closer as the
one of the objects has stated yeah a
fair comment Fair Point Council Keane
can we have
to show in the properties as they are
now please
bear with us a moment Council Keen
is that the one in New York but
foreign
I think I just want to raise a point
about the plans
um and the concern about the accuracy of
the plans obviously in terms of
um what's been submitted includes
existing site plans there's been no
suggestion that I understand through
um that the process that the existing
plans are inaccurate and I I would I
would be a bit concerned about
suggesting that's necessarily the case
um obviously what we've looked at is
what they've proposed and fundamentally
um if sorry Annabelle again could you go
to the proposed block plan that's okay
um what we've got to look at is the fact
that in terms of if we're just looking
at the site plan and effectively the
block plan what you've got there is you
have a dwelling that's going to become
two-story but that second story is
within the roof
uh you haven't protruded uh
significantly at all past the rear
elevations of the the property either
side so you're not causing a sense of
enclosure to the habitable room windows
which face to the Sea and to the east
you've got a separation distance that is
clearly visible on that plan between the
side of the two properties and obviously
side windows are not treated the same as
habitable room windows which obviously
face front and back and therefore in
terms of the impact on the neighbors
either side there there isn't considered
to be
um yeah an impact that again would
warrant a reason for refusal and again
we have to obviously look at the
previous there is a previous approve
which obviously the footprint was
different
um but yeah we are working the fact
there is a there is a property on there
at the moment as well if obviously it
was enlarged it was larger and it was a
full two story there may well have been
um there may well be more of a concern
but obviously the the bulk of the
property the new part of the property as
well as that depth is actually obviously
at that first floor level but it's
obviously within that pitch and those
two sides are pitching away from the
neighbors so that's why we consider that
that you know it is acceptable as it is
with the relationships as shown on this
proposed bot plan
thank you and does that answer Castle
King
thank you
right so come back to officers
Annabelle can you
yeah just to provide some clarification
we've measured it again and in both
instances going to number 52a from the
existing and proposed it is 3.6 meters
in total to the flank wall and 1.3
meters between the edge of the house as
extended and as existing 54 to its
boundary is 1.3 meters so a total of 3.6
meters if you look at this plan here you
see the light gray areas along these
flank walls
it does not change they are the same as
these ones they've altered and infilled
different bits and created different
openings but the actual walls do not
move it goes the extensions are to the
front and rear
but not to the sides
uh thank you for that and I will Chester
Ian come back sorry I apologies a lot
last time for me to come back I think on
um the the concern that's raised um that
sorry I've just got my head around is
um the the concern about the the Flint
wall obviously the the I I the condition
that was put on the original application
um obviously was for the wall to be
retained and that's still the proposal
now to have that condition which is
condition four so just to clarify on
that point that is still still the aim
and indeed there's been no suggestion
from the applicant indeed they're fully
aware of the conditions that it's to be
removed
thank you and uh councilor Ghana
but it's almost as if Mr Livingstone was
was preempting me but I wasn't going to
ask because my my understanding actually
is
um that the Flint wall actually isn't
there at the moment
that's correct isn't it but I believe
the Flint wall has
has been removed so it was about making
sure that it is replaced then it comes
back
so the condition says in the interest of
visual amenity no what that's the wrong
condition but the condition forces the
front brick and Flint boundary wall
shall be retained as part of the
development yeah
Annabelle
it is my understanding and I'm not the
case officer for the application but I
did understand that there was more of a
slightly more Flint wall there but I
understand the photographs were taken
um
for this application so the Flint wall
and brick wall is is on the photograph
as you can see but I don't know if it
has subsequently been removed or
changed recently so either the Flint
wall will be retained or the flip ball
will be reinstated or enforcement action
will be taken
okay yep they go along with that I think
tomorrow I have a drive over and uh
have a have a look okay I can't see any
other members
did counselor
oh councilman I did have my hand up but
um councilman if I may stop you there
I'm not being rude to you up here it's
quite difficult that's fine I did I
lowered it anyway I was just going to
make good glass in suggestions and say
does it warrant a site visit
I'm going to let Mr Livingston come back
on that one because
it wouldn't be this committee
thank you um also if I may say I I did
see Mrs
um got a hard time going up in debate
there and as I mentioned I can't allow
objectors or people who are proven you
know come back
once it comes to commit the actual
committee so apologies okay members
um I can't see any other
uh it's down to yourselves this
application is down for approval those
in favor please show
oh
those against
abstentions
so that's six against five in favor
so that has uh motion has been lost
so I'm coming back to
nature um
I I I suppose it's remember to propose a
motion
members
cost of aphid
I'd like to suggest a site visit
yeah
yes I think we've discussed this uh
earlier in the week councilor Beaufort
obviously with what's the elections
um so what we would effectively have to
do is defer the application to be a site
visit
uh after the next planning committee
meeting for the committee at that point
um because
um obviously we may have a new committee
and obviously we can't schedule a site
visiting before that meeting
um and I think due to the fact that we
you know may have new members on
planning committee after the election
there will be a period for training of
new members before the next planning
committee in June but obviously having a
site visit before they've had a planning
committee would be tricky I think so I
think that's probably how we do it and
what we might do is provide I suppose an
update to those members
in that June meeting to say there is a
site visit on this particular
application and potentially give a very
brief presentation at the June committee
to then have it come back in the July
committee
if that makes sense yes so we need a
second for that motion yes obviously if
you're quite happy Council Bayfield on
that so yeah proposal yeah I think under
the circumstances it's the only reason
able yep
I can understand that yeah I'd like a
second to please
councilman Moore and do those in favor
so be a site visit and you've been given
the answers
it's the unknown isn't it which uh but
um
uh in favor
it's not unanimous but uh that's carried
thank you members
uh on your genders if you have a printed
copy
um item nine which is
uh 85 Salisbury Avenue has been
withdrawn by the applicant
so that that is not bound to be
discussed
so we move on to
create agenda item 6D and this is for
approval for the peer head shelter at
the harbor in broadstairs and speaking
in favor is Mr Christian miles are you
there I'm here good evening everyone
good evening
I'm Christian miles and um with Warren
Rowe I'm joint business owner of the
jetty and broadstairs
Leslie thank you to thanet District
Council planning department for their
recommendation for approval
for your information and consideration
the area where we've submitted our plans
is quite often subject to vandalism and
anti-social Behavior and also smells
urine which isn't very nice
is very poorly maintained
and hardly ever used anymore as a
shelter with only two old benches
remaining there
we've had old fridges and rubbish
regularly done there and we've even had
a squatter lived there in his car for a
few months
we've worked with our architect
to make the new proposals as visually
pleasing as possible
and we've kept the development as
authentic within the local area as we
could
we've put six new benches within our
proposal respecting the shelter that the
building is portrayed to offer
both Warren and myself are passionate
about the jetty and making it into a
destination an amazing destination
destination for broadstairs
since registering the application we've
received incredible feedback and support
from local businesses local people and
our customers
so far we've invested half million
pounds in transforming a basic takeaway
into a beautiful Bistro I know some of
you have been there
subject to approval we we intend to
spend a further 500 000 pounds on the
development which will bring a massive
boost for tourism and the local economy
and create jobs for local people
and finally and quite importantly we're
paid we would be paying thanks District
Council rent extra rent to be there
thank you for your time and
consideration
thank you very much uh uh I I don't I
don't come into the um
talking issue gather with the committee
but can you put the Viking ship motive
back up there that was there when I was
younger I have heard about that but yeah
maybe for another time
right Emma to give the report please
thank you chairman this
of the jetty in um broadstairs Viking
Bay so the area
um is in this location here at the end
of The Jetty the existing
um
commercial unit and this area on the
right hand side is the shelter and so
the proposal is to extend underneath the
shelter in the areas you can see
outlined in red
so this is the existing building
and then these are some photos of it so
you can see on the right hand side here
is is the commercial unit that exists
and then the area of the left here is
the open shelter
and some more photos you can see there's
existing bike storage space within it
again you can see here and these are the
two benches that were just referred to
and again you could just see another
view so basically it's just a shelter
area there's limited C team with just
those two benches within the within the
site
the site does live in the conservation
area so we need to assess the impact on
on the Conservation Area
and again just views taken from the
jetty of different
um elevations so you can see Viking Bay
in the distance there
and then the existing commercial units
and then again another view of the of
the unit so this is from the Western
elevation
and then long distance view of the
building so
um The Proposal doesn't involve any
expansion outside of the area covered by
the roof so it's all underneath the
existing roof so it's all infield
underneath and so this area here that's
you could currently see through that
would be in field so you wouldn't be
able to see through the building anymore
and then just long distance view so this
is the existing site layout
and then this is a Pros you can see
where the extensions are going so
there's one single story extension in
this location here and then at this area
here so this area between the two would
remain open so that would um still
um provide the bike storage space and
some overhanging shelter space but
otherwise these these two areas would
infill the remainder of the area
underneath the roof
so this is the existing south south
facing elevation so the view towards the
sea
and this is the proposal the extension
on the right hand side here
and then this is the existed west facing
so this is towards the the beach area
and this is the um extension that you
can see here so in terms of materials
it's all proposed to be
um
vertical horizontal black cladding
um and black aluminum
framed windows
and then this is the north facing
elevation
and then this is the um proposed
elevation showing the infill of the
extension you can see the proposed
benches in this location here so to the
north six um benches are proposed
outside the um extension area
and then this is the east facing
elevation and this is a proposal so in
this area here these are
um concrete framed picture windows and
again you can see the aluminum frames
and then the black clad in which is in
keeping with the existing cladding on
the building
this is the existing layout of the
building so you can see the commercial
kitchen here this is the seating area
but this area here is is the area that's
all um open at the moment and then this
is the proposal so the extension to the
north here is accommodating a wet fish
hatch an ice cream hatch and then this
area on the right hand side here is
expanding the existing Commercial
Business provide a larger restaurant
area
in this location here there would be
some toilets provided and again you can
see the benches and to the northwest
side so six benches in this location on
the right hand side there are four
additional benches and these are
actually also sea defense benches that
would
um direct over topping water away from
the extension so environmental age the
environment agency have been consulted
on it and the happy that um that that
would not cause any concerns so but
require the condition that requires the
benches to be provided prior to the use
commencing so there's going to condition
requiring that all of these benches are
provided prior to the youth commencing
so in terms of actual space at the
moment there's only there's been two
objections of coming to the application
to do with the loss of the space but as
you saw it is
underutilized really there's only the
two existing benches within that space
the fact that they're looking to
re-provise benches and provide
additional benches and also provide
additional facilities such as the toilet
and the expansion of the business
it is supported in principle the area is
covered by policy sp12 of the planet
local plan which supports proposals that
maintain and enhance the role and
character of broadstairs and supports
opportunities to enhance the use and
attractiveness of the Promenade seafront
and Beach and supports small-scale
Leisure and tourism uses so this would
be fully supported by the policy in
terms of the impact on the conservation
area the fact it's not expanding beyond
the existing footprint of or the roof
area of the building means there's not
considered to be any significant impact
on the conservation area so it's all
in-field underneath the existing
building so the impact on long distance
fuses is considered acceptable
um
so yes it's supported in principle
there's no concerns in regards to
neighboring living conditions because
it's so far from any neighbors
um and so it is recommended for approval
thank you thank you Emma I recommend uh
obviously the officer's recommendation
which is to approve because Council
disruptly second I'll second that chair
thank you members
Council bayford
yeah totally in support of this
application
um I think the area is not put to good
use at the moment the restaurant is is
excellent I think it will be completed
to a very high standard
um there's no there's no no potential
harm to Residents because of its
location
um excellent for for tourism so I'm
totally in support of this application
thank you thank you councilor every
I agree with councilor Byford
cool that was quick
thank you Council Moore yes thank you
chair
um on that uh new layout oh where's the
bin storage area or the Bin's going to
be on the pier as they are at the moment
uh secondly I noted that in one of the
pictures it doesn't seem to be any
partitioning from the car Park area to
the pier shelter as there is or there
should be
um because there's no vehicular access
to go on to that
um and that that railing and fencing is
there for that reason
um so I'm just wondering whether that's
part of the development to put that back
um and where the bins are because the
otherwise the bins are just on the
Promenade on itself I presume the
building is still owned by TDC or is it
now
yeah so TDC need to bring that back in
and make sure those things are
reinstated because at the moment they're
missing think you wish to come back
um yeah
yeah and by TDC which is why it's been
brought before members um tonight in
terms of the bin storage area that's in
this location here the center of the
site so that area is outlined for for
bin storage
um in terms of the other point you
mentioned I'm not quite sure what you
mean I'll go back to the photos
um
uh
are you talking about on the left hand
side here
I don't know if there's a better view so
you're saying that something's been
removed
I'm not sure I'm afraid sorry um yes
there is there would have been
um a wooden barrier preventing vehicles
to drive forward towards the the shelter
and there was a wooden gate the wooden
gate disappeared and a metal gate turned
up now the metal Gate's gone
um so I don't know whether the
developers had a gate there to reinstate
the damaged one but I think that railing
is missing at the moment because it's
not clear from that picture thank you
Council Ian's coming back I think even
though it's it's not directly relevant
with regards to the extension but I
think in terms of raising that point I
think we will pass it on to colleagues
who deal with both of the estate side of
things to separately find out what's
what's going on on that matter
well um I'm a big fan of um tourism in
the area of the whole of the area of all
of our towns and I've only ever heard
good things about the business down
there at the jetty so uh like Council of
eight foot I will be supporting this
application thank you councilor wing uh
yeah I think it's I know I call it a
small project but it's not a significant
amount of money uh you know it's the way
forward we've got so many derelict
shelters that maybe this will lead the
way in in us being brave enough to
convert some of our other shelters uh
the only objection I have that it's not
in central Harbor Ramsgate
do you going over there with colleagues
and moving it uh Council Walling did you
put your hand up
thank you chair
um
knowing the area very well as I do that
shelter is in a terrible condition at
the moment I think any work that's done
down there will be a massive Improvement
the proposals that have been put forward
uh
uh are very high quality and very good
and I think that four broad stairs
itself this can only be a big benefit so
I will be supporting this application
thank you thank you members uh I can't
see anybody else shout at me if I can't
look okay I'm going to put this to you
um those in favor of this application
please show
I don't think I need anybody against is
anybody against
that is unanimous thank you members and
good luck thank you
right uh gender item
6G which is a little Upton Vale Road in
broadstairs uh speaking against this
application is Mr David Brian Mr Brian
you're there good evening
because it has three minutes thank you
dear committee members ladies and
gentlemen uh thank you for the
opportunity to speak in opposition to
this application
um I did underestimate the size of the
room but I do have here a picture it's a
photograph of three proud looking
awarding ladies dressed in all their
finery sitting outside the front door of
little Upton Circa 1900s
a view which is now partially blocked by
a monstrosity of a non-authorized
outbuilding built by the current owner
which incidentally is one of six on
authorized buildings built recently
within the cartilage
this an authorized building not only
detracts from the once lovely view of
this grade two listed building
with its curvilinear Gable it's sport
the entire look of the once Grand Farm
setting
it does nothing to enhance protect or
preserve the characterful presence of
this once proudly owned listed property
this construction only serves the
benefit of the current custodian but as
a result the shear imposing size and its
position now overshadows the listed
building of architectural and historic
interest
or therefore hope the committee comes to
the only plausible conclusion which is
to reviews this application
and should this application be granted
we fear that further obtrusive and
unauthorized outbuildings and building
work will follow
but finally I know this isn't a reason
for refusal but I'm extremely
disappointed in the amount of vegetation
Hedgerow and trees which have been
removed along the inner Flint wall
which used to house bats which could be
seen at flying between an ancient oak
tree which is the TPO upon it and now
remove trees but no longer thank you
uh thank you very much now going to hand
over to our officer which I believe is
Emma
Annabelle
it's that time of night I think
Annabelle okay thank you chair
so yes uh this is little Upton and it
has been mentioned it's listed as
solicited earned property it's gray two
listed
um the application relates to this
hatched building here which is a
retrospective application so it is in
place and we'll be able to look at some
photographs of it and it's an
outbuilding that did replace an existing
out building which was
different in characters more of a shed
like
outbuilding with a felt roof so we'll
have a look at this building
that's currently there
so this is the picture of the
outbuilding you can see the a grade two
listed little Upton there and this is
the existing outbuilding that's in place
and which members are considering
tonight
so again some pictures of it so we can
see the list of building and this is the
outbuilding and the uh the Flint wall
that's been mentioned
um the
it's not in a conservation area and the
tree with the TPO is oh I asked I'll
stop now
to happen tonight
sorry yes uh
um sorry yes it's not in a Conservation
Area although the building is listed
and the tree of the TPO is still on site
but some vegetation that used to
sit within the property has been removed
so the site is more visible from public
Vantage points
um this is an actual image from Google
so it's not a photograph taken by one of
our officers but as you can see you've
got the listed building here
the outbuilding that we're discussing
and considering tonight and you'll note
that the Flint wall is relatively low in
the pavement quite high so you can get
views over that flute wall
of into little Upton and its curtilage
um some more views taken from across the
road so you can see the outbuilding
there the Flint wall
again moving around you can see the um
Frontage of little Upton and the the
roof of the building there
and again we're moving along
um Fell Road
and looking back on
the outbuilding here so you can see it
is above the wall and we've as we've
seen from when you're standing next to
it you can get fused down into it
and again enough of you looking further
back towards the outbuilding on the
left-hand side of that slide
so the building itself is
um 3.8 meters wide has a length of 6.4
meters
and is actually in its own right not a
badly designed building it's so no
objection is actually raised
to it in its own right but it does fail
to respect the appearance and
sits in a location that dominates
um
the actual listed building and fails to
have that relationship with it it feels
more in keeping as the conservation
officer mentions in her in the officer
Report with some of the extension Zone
other buildings that have Works have
taken place but it is a dominant feature
when you look at
it's in relation to
um
the listed building so the officer
recommendation that it is overly
dominant it does affect the setting of
the listed building and a date and
Cottages that all form part of the group
with the listed buildings so he offices
of recommendation is to refuse the
application
thank you chair
are you caring about I move the
officer's recommendation which you've
heard could councilor shrub please
second second that Jeff
thank you members
I think you Council King
um so can I just
a building is used for and also is it
any taller than the previous building
thank you
can
Annabelle
same tonight
it's my understanding it is just a
general outbuilding an association with
um
it's not like an Annex or any particular
use it is just the garden building as I
understand it
I don't have the measurements of the
building that was replaced but I do
understand it was slightly
potentially smaller but not
significantly smaller but it was a more
sort of shed light for want of a better
word appearance
so
please Madam I'm sorry I can't
uh Council Beaufort
yeah my understanding was that
placed
that's an also in very very poor
condition so I can't really understand
why that was okay and this isn't
thank you Council crinton
I think my question is very much along
the same lines is um as what we've
already heard is what was there before
and how is how is this different what
did what did the previous Building look
like
thank you
um so what I will do is I will try and
show you via Google street view
um over the the previous years so one of
the things that somebody occurred has
mentioned with regards to the
outbuilding sorry the Landscaping being
reduced is that we've
um there were restricted views into the
site which are now uh sort of I suppose
increased by virtue of the Landscaping
going but if I quickly just present my
screen
um and again so this is this is again
the records that are provided um to
everyone uh via product form so here is
the view of the site uh using Google at
the moment if I go back in time
um you can see that there was
Landscaping there previously
um what you may be able to see here
though is
a single story flat roof shed that I
think again I can't tell you the
specifics of the size of it but I think
from from the appearance wise if I then
skip back you can see that it's quite
notably bigger
okay thank you
Council Towny
I am I quite agree with councilor beer
for the Crypt did it's uh it's replacing
your building and I understand it was
there before and I suppose it's been
built on the original footprints that
were there as well
and I can't understand why it's being
rejection or the business offer and not
actually
it consistent with the rest of their
building area because it's not under
Conservation Area so why should that be
effective in any way
um cue just just to come back on that I
think that there's no question that the
building that's been constructed needs
planning permission because an
outbuilding in the grounds of a list of
building doesn't isn't permitted
development so you need planning
permission for it
um we haven't we can't ascertain
um in terms of uh from our records there
doesn't appear to be planning perfect
for the shed there's a question of
whether or not the shed itself was was
operational development depending on how
it was fixed to the ground
um it could have been effectively a
temporary structure but what's being
judged is what they've proposed so we
can obviously look at as we have what
was there but obviously they've built a
new building and so it does need to be
judged on its own merits and obviously
it does have a a different sort of scale
should we say to what was there I think
the concerns that we have that's
obviously been put forward by the
conservation officer and obviously
you've seen the comments that are in the
report
um that have been received
um is as Annabelle said that the
building itself in itself is is is well
designed but it is not located in the
right place on the site as we would say
the
um the view that you now get and indeed
you would have got at different times in
year depending on the Landscaping
through to the frontage of the of the
building
um has obviously been altered and
obviously what now you you know you can
see that the the elevation with the the
effectively the bay window if I go back
you'll see the you can see the bay with
the Flint work on the right hand side
there which obviously and in terms of
the view is obscured by virtue of this
uh this development
um there was a previous application
which is referred to in the conservation
officer's comment
um from 2006 which is not necessarily
relevant in terms of looking at building
on this site but that was actually
looking at an outbuilding where there
are currently temporary outbuildings on
the right-hand side and again in the
same way it was considered that the
impact on the setting of little Upton by
virtue of the way it addresses the open
space the you can see on that plan is an
important part of its setting and indeed
its significance so whilst it's not in a
Conservation Area the council has a
statute duty to ensure that designated
Heritage assets are preserved or
enhanced and we do not consider that
there are public benefits to outweigh
the harm that's caused from the
outbuilding where it is
no thank you in Council Ghana
thank you
um
I'm going to speak in full support of
the planning officer's recommendations
with this application
um over the last couple of years
I've become very familiar with this site
both one it's not that far from where I
live walking up and down and I've become
very familiar or increasingly familiar
with the building over those years as
every time as frequently when I've
walked past or driven past more and more
of the trees for and growth around the
wall where where you wouldn't have
noticed the original building because of
that has disappeared and been removed
and I I did dispute
um a couple of years ago when I was
contacted I did get in touch with
enforcement but although the the TPO
tree is still in place I do feel that
some of the growth Associated around
that TPO TPO tree should have been
considered
um necessary for enforcement because it
shouldn't have been removed
but the the facts are clear
um the building needs planning
permission it hasn't got planning
permission and it should be refused
end off
thank you Council Garner councilor
Everett
yeah I'm also going to support the
planning officer's recommendation
um I think there's no question that it
um that it affects the setting of the
listed building
um it's in the wrong place it might be
possible to put it somewhere else on the
site
um it's not of itself unattractive but
it clearly obstructs views of the
holistic building
and I don't think we should be
permissive and granting these things
just because people build them and I
think what was there previously was much
less obtrusive
um and I should be supporting the
recommendation
thank you councilor wing
because the fact it's not in a
conservation area is irrelevant because
I think there's some concept of
cartilage so a historical building has a
cartilage which is the the rest of its
site so whatever you're building that
site needs to relate in some way to the
listed building what's interesting the
building at the Top If we could go back
to a picture of the one we see the
building
that that one that one there it also
seems that it's built of this black this
total black material which is totally
out of keeping with the sort of red
brick of the the listed building I sort
of fully support the officers uh refusal
of this because it just sticks out like
a sore thumb it just doesn't relate in
any way shape or form to the building it
looks a nice building in itself but it's
it's in the wrong place but it the
building behind it is also interesting
because it's also built with this black
stuff apart from
so it's completely different to the red
brick of the historic building so it's a
shame thank you Council Quinton come
back uh yeah I'm going to take a
slightly different view it seems to me
that
um the problem is less about the look of
the building than the fact that you can
now see it because the vegetation has
gone whereas the vegetation before was
hiding something dilapidated and yucky
now we can see something that looks a
bit smarter but
is now a problem because we can see it
um so I'm really not I'm struggling with
the officer's recommendation
thank you
and Health members wish to cancel right
um I will be supporting the offices
record recommendation
partly because
it sends a message out to people who
just think they can build anything and I
think we need to it it's not often we
get an officer that supports
a retrospective being dealt with and I
think therefore we should be supporting
the officer
thank you um I can't again see any other
hands so I'm going to put this to you
which
two members which is
um officer's recommendation is for
refusal those in favor of that
those against
abstentions
right the office recommendation has been
carried
for refusal
don't need anything else do you nope
thank you for that members that
concludes public speaking for this
meeting I'm going to hand over to
Stephen now to read out the two items
which are on your agenda which
incidentally are they're on there
because they are Planet District Council
properties so Stephen and if you wish to
speak about them please shout at me
thank you thank you chair uh a05 public
conveniences Stone Pier bargate
and a06 never caught Turing Park never
caught Hill Ramsgate
that's it
no I can't see anybody wishing to speak
thank you that for so therefore members
can I have a proposal to move that the
applications that have not been reserved
be determined by in accordance with the
officer's recommendation could have a
proposer several hands going up
councilor Beaufort okay do I have a
second
Captain
right members agree
thank you members that concludes so
before you go could we have a quick word
um I'm gonna have a quick word as well
yeah
um
yeah right
um it will be brief um I think you know
uh most of you anyway
um I've been around in this place for
the last 20 years
um
call me what you like I think it's right
that um
I say just a couple of words of thanks
to people especially on planning I've
enjoyed planning I think it's a very
difficult one for you I know about a
chair
you don't get too involved and sometimes
you can but then you're in trouble so
I know committee has changed in the four
years I've been chair
I'd like to thank you and you know you
put up with me I think we work well
together
um and also with the officers
I'm gonna get me Kleenex out
but yes it's going to be strange I've
been on most committees in this Council
or
I have to say I've enjoyed it I've
enjoyed the people whoever they are and
I think most people know that from me
and I'm not going to be political at all
I never have been um but I wish all of
you well I mean the election's coming up
if you're standing
um as you gather I'm not but I do want
to say goodbye because I'm sure we will
see each other somewhere I'd like to
think that we can always say hello
yeah
sorry
so again
um it's going to be strange but
again thank you for yeah
helping me
if you wish I know that's it Mr chairman
I can say what I like so um I obviously
want to say thank you to the chair who's
been very supportive of officers
throughout um the last you know the last
four years yeah
um and also thank you to all of you
um because you know planning committee
is as I said for those that attended
various training sessions over the time
it is really difficult it is really
difficult for members on planning
committee and it is every decision is
difficult every decision affects lives
and I think whilst of course you haven't
agreed with us in every instance I think
it's been always in good Candor it's
been a healthy debate and you have made
developments better uh when you know
changing changing certain things so I
think it's you know it's or as as the
chair said for those that are standing
all the best and if you are standing I
hope to see you back for planning
committee in June with that site visit
that you've voted on
so thank you Ian
that's it
all right thank you very much
I have left a little cap up here
um which um thank you members and and
take care going home good night